this is jocko podcast number 281
with echo charles and me jocko willing
good evening echo good evening
alarm goes off i wake up
it's zero 600. same time i woke up
yesterday
and the day before actually since june
28th almost 120 days ago
four months that's okay though
because if anyone in the persian gulf
tries to interfere with the
policies of my sacred country the united
states of america
i'll be there to stop them
two months ago it was anyone in the
mediterranean
actually we could stop anyone in the
world
breakfast time 45 minute wait in line
every meal is the same stand in line
sweating
that's okay though there are people in
my country who neither know
nor care that their freedom is being
protected at this very moment
that too is okay because i do know
i'm doing it go to work
the same routine day in and day out
it could be compared to being in jail
except that the work
we do is too hard and too dangerous to
impose
upon a common criminal
it would be considered inhumane
that's okay though i understand
freedom and the sacrifices that have to
be made for freedom to be achieved
the life we live at the cost of our
military members
cannot have a price put on it
if you saw our paychecks you would
understand
dinner time chicken and rice again
that's okay the opportunities
we have in the states are limitless
there's nothing that any person cannot
achieve
if he or she has the heart
they don't have those opportunities in
the parts i've visited
they don't even have taco bell
and that right there is a litter letter
written by
steve voigt written on october 23
1996.
he was killed in a helicopter crash on
october 25th
1996 two days after he wrote that letter
steve was at seal team eight
when that helicopter crash happened
while they were training
and i went through sealed training with
steve
in 1991 bud's class 177
and he was an old man at the time
he was like 28 or 29 years old
and he was our he was our class
leading petty officer
and was just an awesome guy and i know
he was from the south i think he was
born in georgia
but he didn't have
he didn't have a typical southern accent
he had
this other he had this other voice that
probably one of the most distinctive
voices i've ever known
and he was really loud and so he had
this
distinctive lap this distinctive loud
funny voice it was kind of like this
he'd say hey guys get over here he had
this just
totally distinctive voice you couldn't
miss it
and he was tough as hell and the
instructors tried to crush him all the
time
because he was an older guy and a senior
guy was a first-class petty officer
so being that senior going through basic
seal training
the instructors are going to get at you
and they got at him and they hammered
him
but they they couldn't break him at all
and they actually couldn't even get him
to crack a little bit
because they'd be punishing him and he'd
be hitting the surf
and he'd be doing push-ups and he'd be
doing sprints
and they'd ask him about something and
he'd still come off the same with that
loud
just crazy funny voice and we'd rally
right around him
just a freaking awesome guy
and when he died
you know it was 1996
there's no war going on right so it was
definitely a shock to the system
to have someone killed like that
and just tragic and horrible and i knew
that
you know he had a son and he had had a
son because like i said he was older
but he had he had a son that was named
after him another
another stephen voight
and i knew that but i you know i kind of
lost track with him
i was on the west coast he was on the
east coast i didn't go to the funeral
for whatever reason and i just carried
on with my career
and you know continue to try and serve
to the best of my ability
always remembering
always remembering steve voigt and his
sacrifice
what about a son
and what happened to him well
fortunately
fortunately there was
support for him
and he was able to grow up and he was
able to go to college and all that was
taken care of
by a group called the special operations
warrior foundation and what that group
is
is one of the things that they do one of
the main things that they do is they
take
care of the children of fallen members
of the special operations community
and and steve's son got taken care of
in that respect the special operations
warrior foundation
stepped up and
paid for his education and and gave
young
stephen the opportunities
that his father was not there to give
to him but that his dad had sacrificed
for and this story
is one of thousands of stories
of thousands of families that have been
helped by this foundation
and we are lucky enough today to have
the president and the ceo of this
incredible charity
here a man who has quite a story of his
own
from an enlisted marine at age
17 to 41
years of service resulting in the rank
of major general two star
with service in panama iraq afghanistan
and a bunch of other places around the
world
general clay hot mocker
clay thanks for joining us hey thanks
for having me jacqueline appreciate it
that's a great
story i i never heard of that letter i
appreciate you sharing that
i was looking at some videos that you
all have produced
and steve voigt's picture i mean just a
picture of him and his son when his
son's young
and uh man i couldn't i couldn't believe
couldn't believe when i saw that and i
just it struck me that you know i
i was in the i was in the military what
what can you do this is something that
we always feel
when you're in the military you lose
somebody
you you want to help but you also have a
job and you're going to continue to do
that job
and so organizations like yours that
can pick up the slack for the guys that
are still serving
and and have a long-term strategic plan
to take care of these families
and just seeing his son who who
definitely looks like him you guys have
a video of one
of him on there as well and just seeing
his son who looks like him
doesn't quite sound like him doesn't
quite sound like him man his voice was
distinctive hey what are you guys doing
over there
um but just awesome
to that that you have that
that organization that that helps in
that respect so
we'll get to that but before we get to
that let's
let's start it well let's let's start at
the beginning i always like to start at
the beginning
so where where did you grow up i grew up
in washington state
i was born in wenatchee washington
bounced around a bit
and ended up before i joined the
military in a little town
outside of everett washington called
lake stevens and
yeah i was living in a foster home
dropped out of high school
and rec all i knew is i needed a kick in
the ass and i figured well
the marines they'll definitely do that
and they did not disappoint
so you're in you were in foster homes
from what age uh
that was maybe i joined when i was 17
i guess 15. my parents divorced when i
was young
and i bounced around and then you know a
lot of this was my own doing you know to
be perfectly honest with you i was you
know sort of done with my
parents and wanted to you know they had
moved from lake stevens and i was like
hey i'm not i'm not doing that
with all the wisdom that a 15 year old
possesses you know
and so this is what 1975
uh yeah if you want to round up a couple
years that'd be fine too but uh
but i'm saying it's 1975. you're 15
years old you're living in foster homes
you're like to hell with the parents i'm
doing my own thing
what did you have any uh did you think
we just just short-sighted not
well it was you know actually it was a
little later than that my mother was a
writer she passed away last year
december a year ago last december and
she was in south africa
if you ever saw that movie cry freedom
with denzel washington
it was about this guy donald woods who
was the editor of a newspaper over there
which
was on the coast of south africa she
worked for him
so i lost that whole year over there
with her in early 76 i came back because
the school didn't count right
oh so you went there you went to school
yeah i lived in east london south africa
between durban and cape town
and that was a little slice of the
marine corps right there i mean uniforms
haircuts and school and the whole deal
which you know i did not adjust well to
that by the way and it received the
caning
numerous canings for that oh they got
their corporal punishment
oh yeah bamboo canes i mean once in a
wet speedo for not counting off properly
and mandatory pt
and uh you know i got religion pretty
quick learned how to count for sure
uh but uh yeah that's like prime
apartheid time it wasn't yeah this was
this newspaper was obviously against
apartheid
so you know we were right in the middle
of all that i mean it was really stark
seeing the way that the way life was
over there so anyway i came back from
that i'd lost a year in high school and
i'm like well
you know look i wasn't you know an
academic champion anyway
so i was like i'm just going to join the
marines and i
am i i that's when i got back from there
didn't want to move back where my dad
was i was living with a guy and then a
foster home took me in it was that it's
a pretty cool story he
this family the williams family i'm
still in very close touch with them
their son had died and he was a
motocross racing is big up there for
teenagers and he had died he was my
classmate jeff williams and he had died
in a motorcycle crash
and so i knew the family from afar not
not close i wasn't close friends with
jeff but but we knew each other
and so then it was sort of fortuitous
you know that i
providence that i came in his same age
and ended up with this family
and her the father charlie williams
was a former marine from korea and so he
was tell me about the marine corps and i
see that's what i need
so signed up and shipped out to the warm
embrace of the marine corps
so that did did what did he do in korea
did you
capture some of those stories that he
was in korea no
yeah he you know he was i think he was a
combat engineer
and uh you know so he was you know i
mean i don't remember a lot of them but
you know he talked a lot about combat
and how
you know bad it's like but really the
best stories for him were boot camp
you know they pulled all of it i never
forget one he said they pulled all of
his teeth out and we're giving him
dentures
you know when he's in boot camp right so
obviously dental care was not high on
his priority list
and right after he had that he had
stitches in his mouth and the drill
instructor pulled his dog tags pulled
him towards him real fast and then
extended his fists and punched him in
the mouth and his whole
you know mouth exploded with blood and
everything else and that's why are we
supposed to be laughing at this
yeah i was like that sounds like fun i
think i'll join you know so
uh i mean those were most of his stories
for the trauma you know when i look at
full metal jacket in those
boot camp scenes i mean my d.i
said a lot of those same phrases that
they were i mean i thought that was
authentic what was that guy who ended up
being an actor gunny
yeah yeah yeah he was you know the yeah
i guess at first he was a technical guy
but then he ended up
playing a part and i was like that dude
could have been staff sergeant amerine
who was my senior d.i
when i went through so so you showed up
there in 1978 so these guys are yeah
you're still getting
you're still getting vietnam guys are
your drill instructors
yeah my company you know in the marine
corps in a company you have a first
sergeant
you know and in the nco ranks you can
sort of split at e8 you can either be a
master sergeant or a first sergeant
and in a company traditionally you have
a first sergeant who sort of runs all
the admin
and all that then you have a master
sergeant who does ops right he's like
the op sergeant
and i remember my first op sergeant i
mean he had one eye from vietnam and he
was illiterate
i mean he would sign like a x on the
duty roster and stuff like that i was
you know i mean yeah there was some
it was definitely a lot of vietnam era
guys there and how do you adapt
um candidly poorly at first you know i
mean
when i got there you know i mean it was
shock and awe
and i you know i certainly didn't want
to be there and for probably the first
few weeks thought i had made
a monumental error in judgment but
there was just enough in me that i felt
like hey
i'm you know i'm not going to go back to
my family hat and hand with my tail
between my legs so i just you know
tried to do it day at a time but i do
remember you know
the first morning they wake you up it's
brutal right trash cans thrown over
pulling people out of bunks and
you know there was a lot of physical
abuse back then i mean it was you know
measured but seemed pretty violent to me
but you know i remember laying in a in
my rack every morning before you know
because i could hear them moving around
like little mice positioning themselves
before they launched the
all-out assault and uh you know and i'd
be later and i'd be like well what do i
have to look forward to today
well that would be nothing so
once i got out of the rack and i started
going you're like a muscle memory i was
fine but those were the worst parts was
that morning laner knowing this
onslaught that was gonna you know start
there in a couple of minutes
but all that being said you know i mean
and i and i think i was sort of a jack
wagon for my first comments typical
you know i did well in boot camp i got
whatever meritorious pfc and all that i
think primarily because my drill
instructor was hot for my sister
um but you know i'd take any leg up i
could get
uh but you know the first couple years i
did all this
i went to lejeune to second mar div out
there and i did all the stupid stuff
that young troops did you know blow all
my money for the
first three days after payday you know
thank god i had a meal carter i would
have starved to death
um but then you know the i went to
okinawa to third mar div
and that's when the sort of the light
came on and i started going to school i
got my
diploma and started going to college and
i mean you know and then once you get a
little success
you know you sort of build on that i
mean there's setbacks along the way
but then i was like okay i can do this
you know what was your mos
i was in 1833 amtracker get some
yeah when you when you say was there
anything that made you realize
hey i need to kind of step up my game
maybe i should start you know going to
college maybe i should start my
continuing education maybe i should
start trying to get advanced
was there anything that in particular do
you have a leader that mentored you did
you just look around and say
man why don't i do a little bit better
well do you remember what that was
was it think one thing yeah it wasn't
you know there wasn't a specific leader
there were later in my life certainly
those that
you know that really inspired me to go
above and beyond
um but at that stage i think it was
more seeing people crash and burn around
me you know i mean
getting guys getting kicked out for
drugs was rampant
back then i mean it was really ram i
mean and
uh and guys were getting caught we
didn't do urinalysis or anything like
that i mean they were just physically
cut with
you know drugs in the barracks it was
open bays back then we were open bay
barracks
at courthouse bay which is where our our
battalion was
and i just saw these guys and i mean i
just saw him failing
and i mean i knew they were on a
downward spiral and i think
over time i saw enough of that where i
was like okay i don't want that to be me
and i went to okinawa with sort of in
you know
my own personal mandate to to turn
my life around and you know make
something of myself hey you know listen
it was never part of the training
on the training calendar for me to be a
general officer i remain amazed of the
flaws and the promotion system of this
day
but you know i just i just my goal was
to be a sergeant frankly that was my
goal
and uh and you know but you know you get
a little victory and you sort of build
on that
and you know and then lo and behold here
i am
you know flag flying and everything so
you know
as you know as a former aide you know
yeah yeah so
when you when you
how did you originally hear because you
ended up going to the warren officer
flight program right right
how did you originally hear about that
well i re when i was at the rock okinawa
i re-enlisted and uh i went to i got my
duty station a choice or whatever and it
was marine barracks whidbey island
washington which is now long since
closed
and i was working as a bouncer in the
globe and anchor club
you know we had our own enlisted club at
the corner of our barracks
and there was a reserve a marine reserve
helo
unit that was a huey unit that was on
the base there
and some guy um
pixley urix was his name was walking by
with this brochure and it had a cobra
hovering over the trees and a morning
mist coming up and i'm like hey what
what's that and he said hey it's this
army warrant officer flight training i
mean i barely knew what a warrant
officer was i mean i was like you know
the marines memorizing ranks and all
that stuff every night he had to recite
him before he went to bed and boot camp
but
you know and i said don't you have to
have a degree and i probably had you
know i don't know less than a year of
college at that time
and he said no so i started you know i
was like
so i took the brochure he gave it to me
and we both ended up
you know he ended up ultimately in
joining the co he got into the army
warrant officer program and then flew uh
58 uh you know little scout helicopters
then ended up transferring into the
coast guard but
i went through the process i drove down
to fort lewis
and did my physical down there took all
my flight aptitude tests
and of course right before i was getting
ready to ship out for this you know the
marine corps being the marine corps
they're like hey you've been back you
know for 18 months from the rocks we're
gonna send you back to the rock and i
was like perfect
you know so the army graciously delayed
my entry into flight school for the 18
months i went over there did my time
you know came back from okinawa went to
the separation center at camp pendleton
and then three days later i was at fort
rucker alabama i had
i didn't know anything about the army i
mean i had nothing
you know and it showed you know i mean
like drilling ceremony and all that
stuff they do it you know not completely
different but def
differently enough that i was dropped
for push-ups frequently in
warren officer canada's school but went
through
that opted for blackhawks that was like
sort of a new
airplane back then it wasn't brand new
but it was you know pretty hot rock to
get on and i
and i went to 101st how many when you
were going through the
the flight training how many pilots were
getting trained at a time
we just had a vietnam pilot on and he
said
you go out to take off in the morning
there'd be like hundreds and hundreds of
helicopters taking off in the morning oh
yeah it's
it wasn't as bad as vietnam i don't the
intensity wasn't there but
i think they graduated about
50 warren officer pilots and then there
was a commission class
that was you know sort of our you know
they went along through with
us um and we about every
two weeks so they were pumping out
helicopter piles like crazy
um what did you fly as a training bird
uh well i started out in this airplane
the th-55
helicopter which was uh the civilian
designation i think it's a schweitzer
300.
it was a recip reciprocal engine i mean
it sounded like a freaking lawnmower it
was like you know you said about
hundreds of us you know we take off
and we're all in a line these orange
helicopters
and flying out to our stage fields to do
our stuff and then after we checked out
on that
i mean it was a piece of crap i mean
this thing was i mean it's max speed was
like 50 miles an hour or something
uh we i switched over to huey's went
through the
you know transition into that and did
all my instruments and combat
training and you know tactical training
and that and and then
post flight school i went into and went
to the blackhawk aircraft qualcores
how much different is it flying to huey
from flying a blackhawk
much different the rotor systems you
know this is you know i'm getting into
techno geek helicopter speak here but
you know the rotor system's different
it's a semi-rigid and a huey and an
articulated system of lack so that means
you can do a lot more and a black hawk
you know
maneuvering wise and you can do any huey
um the hue
i think i would put it the blackhawk is
like a
g5 and the civilian world jet right
and the huey's like a dc-3 you know so
they're you know it's just their vietnam
all these birds were like you can see on
the tail numbers there were 68
69 vintage
but i still like it i got about 350
hours in those things i got about 160 in
flight school and then the blackhawks
were grounded for a mechanical issue so
i flew
medevac around called in a unit called
flatiron there at rucker so i got a lot
of time in huey so not a lot but you
know
pretty good time we had a we had a top
gun the guy that found the guy that
started top gun was on here
oh no those guys were would just get
into random aircraft
yeah and just take off in jets by
themselves that they'd never flown
before
like including they had they had
captured a soviet mig
and they'd go out and it was in like out
out in
arizona somewhere and they'd fly out
there and they'd get in that thing and
fly that thing
is it is it that transferable with
helicopters
yeah i would say i mean each airplane's
got its own
unique handling characteristics
helicopter but you know the hard part is
starting it for me like okay because you
know
some you got to modulate the throttle
and give gas into the turbine to get it
going and something
i mean so if somebody else starts it or
walks me through how to start it i mean
i can you know you just sort of react to
the plane
you know i mean you see what it's doing
and you would you know you do the
counteraction or you know what you got
to do in the control so the
stick and rudder stuff i think is pretty
transferable i mean i hopped in a
jet long ranger i don't know about a
year ago and i hadn't flown and
you know i don't know five six seven
eight years and
it was no problem because he had to
start it for me you know but
and i wouldn't get into a like flying
instruments in it
or anything like that you lose more of
the procedural stuff like you know
all instruments is you know flying in
the clouds there's a lot of procedure
and things and you got to stay up on
that's a lot of book work so you
understand what's happening
and what your what your responsibilities
are like that i and those atrophied for
me but as far as wiggling the sticks
yeah i could i could hop in a helicopter
was it hard was or did you have any
trouble
going through was there a big attrition
rate did you have any trouble with
anything
uh no not really i
um instruments was pretty challenging
you know you start in the huey simulator
which is
you know um which was you know doing
climbing descending turns with not not
no
outside reference you know you rely on
your visual sense right so
seeing and the horizon and all that way
of course you don't have any of that
in the cloud so they train you on how to
you know get into instruments so that
was
that was challenging a quick story i was
flying in the huey simulator and it's
just
giant like warehouse full of simulators
like this they don't you know they're
really
basic and i'm late at night getting some
extra
flight time in there and the simulator
operator comes over the raid because
he's your air traffic controller guy too
right he's sort of your you know
and i you know made some radio call and
he said uh roger huey one two three four
five
now you gotta fly to geese uh at your
altitude going opposite direction
and i'm like you know looking at this
dude i'm flying with him like what the
hell is this dude talking about
next thing i know this guy's got a mop
and he's slapping it on the
windscreen like he's hitting over the
screen i was like
a little slow out there that i broke you
know
but yeah i mean that was a little
challenging like me i think with me when
everybody else would say the same thing
but no i mean now going into special ops
and re
meeting those standards in the 160th for
you know plus or minus 30 seconds and
all that
there was some there was definitely some
stress there
you know so you get done with flight
school and then
that's when you went to the 101st yep i
was flying medevac
for a delta 326 med but
326 med battalion and i was flying air
ambulance stuff there
when i actually when i got out of flight
squad orders to germany to a place
called schwebisch hall
because one-third of the army back then
was in germany i never realized that i
mean that's pretty significant tells you
the investment we had
uh in the cold war but i heard about
this secret unit
you know uh in fort campbell and i was
like hey that's what i want to do i mean
i don't know what they do i probably
ain't good enough but that's what i want
to
shoot for so i swapped with a guy who
wanted to go to germany
and i went to fort campbell and within a
month you know put when i was in 101st i
walked over to the recruiter
back then to 160 it didn't have any they
didn't wear patches
in anything there was just you know all
there's there was no signs in front of
their buildings
and i said hey i want to join the unit i
was a what we call a wobbly one you know
a warrant officer one junior grade
and they laughed at me and i went back
every month and said
hey you know they told me what i had to
do and you know make pilot in command
and get a lot of night vision goggle
time so i was doing my best to do all
those things and
anyway i kept you know telling them i'm
interested you know persistence
um and then i made it as you know i
didn't realize the difference and you
you
you know in your job in the seals it was
a little different but a warrant is a
technician as you know right so
our warrants in the 160th will stay in
the cockpit and flying the same missions
whether it's
little birds or 60s or 47s for 20 years
and i loved flying i still love flying
but i also miss the leadership
side of that you know being an nco and
from your marine corps days right yeah
and you know there's none of there's i
mean there is some of that in
warnosa ranks but it's it's not their
main focus right by design
uh so i decided to go to officer
candidate school
and and so you know i went to officer
canada school
so you had to apply for that yeah i
applied i'd been going to college still
so i had to have you know two years of
college to
apply for ocs and then you had to have
your four-year degree by the time you
made 03.
so i applied and got picked up but it
was funny i had to
i mean you have to have to be
commissioned you probably remember this
by the beginning of your 10th year
so because you had to be able to do 10
years of commission time was what you
needed to do to retire
by 20. i graduated ocs with nine years
10 months and two weeks like if i would
have got a hang mail or something and
got set back i would have been
out you know and i was a w-2 when i did
you go to full
normal ocs oh yeah listen i got the
distinction i have on my head shaved
more than anybody else i know
no offense of course you're getting
indoctrinated on a regular basis
i'm like the high water bar for you guys
on hair over here which is not saying
much by the way
but you yeah you so you've been through
multitude of in
fresh indoctrinations yeah and also so
how was that how'd they treat you at ocs
what year is this now so i started in
july of 87 and graduated
october 16th i think of 87 commissioned
on that date
so i was technically a year group 88
because that was after the first of the
fiscal year
you know i thought the curriculum at the
course was pretty good we spent about
between a
third and a half of our time in the
field right so we're doing you know
it's really infantry oriented anti-armor
ambushes and ruck marches
and things like that which i thought was
really good
i would say you know the cadre at the
time and it could be different
and i'm in the ocs hall of fame uh
so they may you know disown me over this
but the cadre were not
great i mean they were a guy you know we
had a couple guys i think that had
gotten duis and got sort of stuck
over there you know so it wasn't they
weren't like a great examples of stellar
leadership
in my mind i thought the curriculum was
really good i thought the
quality of the officers that were
mentoring us were not
and you know a lot of the most of the
ocs people that go through in the army
are those that have gotten a degree and
decide after they're outside the window
for rotc
to go into military so they got to go to
basic
and then they go to ocs so you had a
bunch of we had
masters we had a couple of phds i think
in there but i mean they didn't you know
they didn't know
[ __ ] from china i mean they didn't know
you know how's that phd treat yeah
exactly you know
but there was a small percentage of us
that were former you know prior service
you know and they sort of carry the
class and do a lot of mentoring there
was three warrants in our class we had
about 240 250 people in our class
so again good experience
um you know i learned a lot
i i think for instance the marine corps
does a much better job in investing in
their training base than the army does i
mean
um i think that's changing now but
historically
you know the marine corps puts their
best and brightest to develop those
young you know troops and
officers the army really they're more
focused on their tactical units which i
think is at the expense of their future
would be my you know my personal opinion
well when i went to officer candidate
school
it's it's run by marine corps drill
instructors did you go to rhode island
no i went down to pensacola okay and
they're just freaking outstanding i mean
they're just
like exactly what you'd expect they're
just outstanding professionals across
the board
yeah that was my experience i mean my
dis were really really
sharp i mean a little twisted but uh you
know
a little sadism thrown in there but uh
you know they were
very squared away set a great example
for us
so did you so had you already gone to
the 160th at this point so i would it
was funny i had graduate i was getting
ready to graduate ocs i had my packet in
right
i've been over there all those times as
a warrant
and i called the recruiter right before
i was getting ready to graduate and i
was
on orders to go to the 82nd and fly uh
for the 82nd
and i graduated pretty high i wasn't the
number one but i was like
yeah i was gonna ask what's what's the
hall of fame all about well if you know
listen if you're
you know if you make it past colonel and
ocs they
like the funny thing is they say hey do
you want to be in the
ocs hall of fame i was like sure i never
went to the little ceremony right but
they said okay send us 250 bucks so we
can do your pig eyes for love that's a
great deal you know so somewhere in some
hall over there for betting my pictures
up on a wall with a little bio but i've
never seen it never
well at 250 bucks a pop you might be
yeah i was like a lot of company
yeah i was like seriously you guys are
going to charge me to put me in the hall
of the game i was like typical right you
know i'm sure if he went to the navy
olive ocs hall of fame it's probably
very similar
anyway i was getting ready to graduate
and uh
and i thought you know what i'm just
going to call this the recruiter because
you have to go through a week-long
assessment process just to get accepted
conditionally into the unit you know
check rides some physical
standards stuff and i talked to this guy
and he said
and i was you know going to be a second
lieutenant they only took guys that were
had previous flight experience
you know so you had to get one or two
tours but because i had flown as a
warrant
i had about you know 750 hours and i had
approaching 100 nvg hours at the time
which was
pretty good for back then right mvgs you
know now
you know that wouldn't even you know
raise an eyebrow but back then it was
okay so they agreed to uh
put me through the assessment which
pissed my assignment officer off because
i was on my way to the 82nd but
and they told me going in hey look we
don't take lieutenants but
you know you do really well and maybe
we'll bring you back
so i went i sort of approached it with
uh well i'm going to give it my all and
you know they took me so i went there as
a second lieutenant they made me go into
headquarters for a while to learn how to
you know collect for you know
army emergency relief and do all that
kind of crap that you have to do as a
young o
and then i went to a platoon and i ended
up being the first dapp platoon leader
the attack 60s and he probably saw those
in
iraq several times you know i had a
great platoon mike durant cliff walcott
who was killed in somalia october
in fact my middle son who just graduated
college a couple weeks ago was mitchell
walcott hutmacher and uh
donovan briley as co-pilot they were
killed in super six once i had a great
platoon
went to panama together i went to the
gulf flying off the herc
barge hercules yeah so what was going on
in the that's that's what happened first
that was your first
right big mish yeah that was like big
time you know i mean we flew into
bahrain so this is what like 87
80 i got there i did my yeah i got there
actually i got to the unit because i
went through airborne school and did all
that stuff at benning
i got there around february of 88 and i
did my first tour over there is like
there was a logistics cell
at the asu bahrain and so i did that
and then when i went through my training
and got checked out as an mh-60 pilot i
went back over and did two more tours
we'd fly into bahrain
and the outgoing crew would fly off the
barge park it
on the ramp and we we basically swapped
vests with them like we get their combat
vests they gave us their knee board
packets you know we've been on this
freaking rotator from hell for like two
days you know stopping everywhere
sigonella all those places
and we'd hop in the airplane and they'd
get on the commercial flight going out
we'd hop on those helicopters and fly
back out to the barge and
start missions the next night hey when
you when you talked about the training
like uh so once you got to the 160th
how many hours are you putting in what
kind of stress are they put what are
they doing to you to get you up to speed
how long does it take well uh it's
different now than it was then but we
had a
about a i think it's a three week three
week for the o's the officers and
warrant officers
ground phase training so it's ruck
marches
uh you know grappling
you know all those kind of things
shooting we were carrying mp5s which we
ditched after uh
somalia and uh
so we do a lot of that shooting and then
we go into our you know we sort of split
apart the officers do and so you're
either a little bird driver
you're a 60 driver you're a 47 and then
you go through that
you know and you go through what we call
a basic nav phase
and it's basically every night you go
out you got a compass
and a clock and a map you have no you
know there's no
gps no ins no nothing
and they still do it to this way this
way to this day
and you're expected to hit targets plus
or minus 30 seconds and then you take a
check right and then you get all the
bells and whistles and learn all the
systems and how to air refuel
and gunnery and all those kind of things
and they you know they're still very
true to that hey if we tell you we're
going to be there
plus or minus 30 seconds we're going to
be there and you know once we put you in
we're always going to come get you out
i used to tell guys that all the time
hey we put you in we're coming for you
man doesn't matter
you know whatever it takes we're going
to come get you which i think is unique
i'm not saying that other
folks aren't dedicated but that's all we
do right we're
completely dedicated we don't care if
it's a seal a ranger
green beret marsoc raider afsock special
tactics guy we don't care
if you're on the ground you know you're
our customer we're going to do whatever
it takes
so the training really infuses that in
you i mean i was taught a young age hey
they're the customer
we do whatever it takes to support them
and that really
is their ethos in the whole unit how
much is your level of flying
improve in that first like six months
that you're there
well you know it's sort of you probably
found it i think like when you
when you go into that unit the unit's
operating up here right
and you're down here and it really is
sink or swim you either come up here or
your history
you know um and that's true across the
soft community the special ops community
so i mean i i i improved
you know significantly i didn't really
realize it right because it's like when
you're in the midst of it i mean
you know it's like leaving the steel
team and getting in charge of a
recruiting battalion or recruiting
squadron or whatever they have in the
navy you know you're like okay i ain't
in kansas anymore kind of thing you know
uh is the same thing when you're in it
and remember i came there as a second
lieutenant my first
tour outside of soph was as an o5
dang so i did a bunch of time in 120
years or something
yeah close to it i mean i went um
i went to air force special ops command
as an exchange pilot
uh so i after desert storm downing
wanted to sort of bring us together you
never remember the
the mh-53 pavlos in the air force and
160th i mean that was not a harmonious
relationship back then
so you know into his credit general
downing and general holland
said hey we need to mend the fence so i
went to hurlburt
and flew and then they sent a guy up and
i flew there from
92 to 96. it was an instructor pilot i
met my wife there she was a
squadron intel dude so my version is you
know she latched on to the first army
guy
she has a slightly different version of
that but basically the army remains a
subordinate service to the air force in
my own house to this day
so you so let's let's go back a little
bit um
let's go back to panama so you're so
you're a platoon commander
so what does that mean how many birds do
you have when you're a platoon commander
uh
eight six eight something like that um
i had less because the dap the direct
action penetrator defensive arm
penetrator depend on
when you what you call it we were brand
new
um but you know that was big time man i
mean we went down there
and i had i had we had two armed birds
cliff
walcott and i were flying together
and uh was funny we got down there and
they had apaches from the 82nd down
there not with us but you know doing
their stuff
and they wouldn't our commander at the
time for probably good reason somewhat
in good reasons to me as an o1 or o2 but
he said hey you're not going to do
attack i need you to do assault
so the ah six guys who you know out of
general principle despise the dap guys
said hey dap what does that stand for
didn't actually participate
or didn't attack panama you picked i was
like bastards you know
so i mean i laughed about it was very
funny but yeah i went down there was
awesome
we rolled off a c5 you know i got in
there about
two in the afternoon and we started
banging targets that night zero one was
hr they moved it up on the rescue of
curt muse
and uh it was cool i was assigned to a
seal element we were gonna put seals
around the cuban and nicaraguan
embassies they thought that uh noriega
might squirt in there you know
whoever thought he would have went to
the catholic you know the papal and
nuncia for god's sakes you know
but uh yeah we were i was we were
sitting in hangar
three at howard air force base and uh
it was pretty exciting here ac 130
thumping targets and law coming down see
what they're 105
and at one point somebody ran into the
hangar and there was like
you know i don't know i want to say a
thousand it was like cot city in there
somebody said hey they're breaching the
front gate of howard and they shut all
the lights off and i mean you should
charge the handles going over there and
i was sitting next to walcott and i'm
like
no balls to say die gringo and jump up
and yell that in the dark
that was i mean um how long how long
were you flying ops
for then in panama was pretty quick yeah
i mean you know the
real i mean i we flew several night
assaults of course that was a hunt for
elvis looking for noriega for those
first uh
few weeks or first week i guess
um you know but really major combat ops
were uh
were over uh pretty quick and then they
had
you know then we started doing some you
know sort of policing stuff
um remember the dignity battalions they
called we call them the dingbats that
was noriega's sort of
uh thugs that would you know we're
trying to rig the elections and
intimidate people i'll tell you a quick
story so the ranger i can't remember the
name of the town
but north of panama city that we called
them the dingbats the dingbats have
moved in there
and they were um they were harassing the
local populace rape and women doing
stuff like that so they sent a ranger
company up there
you know to uh sort of settle things
down and they sent a
set up this roadblock and uh they had
you know like any kind of blocking
position you have an outer
cord on and then you have the main you
know position here
and so they're all set up and they're
checking cars and this
this car comes careening up to the outer
thing full of four mams you know
military-aged males
busts right through the outer perimeter
so they you know they shoot a law
at it and misses it it goes over the
back of the carpet then they get to the
main position and i mean they just open
up with m60s you know clearly within the
roa
and just shred these guys well it turns
out there were four pdf dudes that were
completely drunk as hell and you know
and they had just
they just you know they were drunk so of
course ranger humor
in the hangar uh or supposed to put up
rad rangers against drunk drivers
that was classy
oh that's freaking yeah i don't know who
did it i just remember seeing that i
mean there's like a little humor there
and uh
yeah howard that blue on blue thing is
well these guys pdf guy these were bad
guys
i mean they were noriega's dude oh they
were they were there with those guys oh
yeah they were just
drunk you know they sort of drunk yeah
they were just they weren't a threat but
we didn't know hey you breached the
guy you know the deal you didn't let
them up as well oh yeah yeah for sure
yeah for sure no i thought you were
saying they were friendly forces no no
no these guys were bad dudes
we didn't have any panama then it gets
really then that then rad is definitely
funny
no definitely yeah yeah yeah i mean you
know yeah rangers against truck drivers
i love it you know
how was the how was the you know from
your looking back now
the mindset down there you know we just
didn't have combat experience
yeah as a country at that time i'm sure
i'm sure
there was a few vietnam guys here and
there but
the bulk of the force or a bunch of
bunch of guys that really didn't have
combat experience
yeah no i mean i don't think there were
any there might have been a couple of
like the senior senior warrants that had
some vietnam but most of those guys have
sort of
been out before this i mean you're
talking 89. so
um and we had practice you know the
original code name for that was blue
spoon
you know and then they changed it to
something you know patriotic you know
just cause or whatever
that sounds cooler yeah but if you go
back to the planning it was blue spoon
was the code name for it
um yeah i was fi i mean i personally i
was like hey this is like
doesn't get any better than this i mean
this is you know this is cool
um so yeah i think we're over eager
you know we i'm sure we made a lot of
mistakes but
you know we're pretty disciplined in our
planning and um
you know i think we're much better now
than we were then obviously
we got a lot of combat time so i just
remember being i remember we
i loaded the airplane it was snowing at
-8 at fort campbell or eight degrees
maybe it was eight degrees i just
remember i stripped off all my cold
weather gear gave it to
some maintenance warrant that wasn't
going with us and i said you know if i
get clipped you can keep this stuff
you know like you don't got to turn it
into the issue facility or whatever
you know very pervado stuff stepping up
the wrap up look at john wayne's going
on
you know yeah it's like a lieutenant
hutbacher man running with scissors you
know and uh
um but yeah i was really excited about
it
and uh you know another funny story we
take off on my this is my
first combat mission a login combat time
you know
and we were flying from howard air force
base out to cologne to fort sherman out
there
and uh it was a daylight flight we were
just and we had our you know our
miniguns we
you know with standard procedure i put
master power on up front and then each
of the
each of the door gunners flips up on a
minigun he's got a
toggle switch and he puts all he was
looking for is power
because then he got two triggers a high
rate and a low rate trigger
but we just checked makes got power to
the guns and it was funny mike durant we
were just telling
i was with him in dallas last week he's
sitting there in the cargo door with his
legs hanging out they got a cargo strap
up and the
gun is slewed back you know just sort of
face and aft
and the guy on the left says yep i got
power and then they shut it down
the guy in the right as soon as he hits
the toggle switch it just starts
shooting
dang well when it was those triggers
were push buttons and they had a rubber
like boot over the top of it and when
they had
somehow something got pushed up against
it and jammed the trigger in
and [ __ ] couldn't see it so durant you
know he's like
geez you know like it was right like
maybe a foot in front of his legs and
got this stream of tracers going out so
it wasn't
and actually or just cleared the housing
area right
by the end of the runway you know and
i'm like
so 0.01 a combat time and i attack
military housing perfect so you know
uh you get done with that yeah and that
that had to feel
like you you know you you got you got
some at least
yeah yeah i mean yeah i mean in rear
view mirror
yeah i don't know that's the thing i
mean we look at all the stuff we did
before september 11th it's like
it seemed cool at the time yeah um
you get back from that and then how much
longer wasn't that much longer
we're jocking up for for desert storm
yeah i think it was like
august when uh saddam hussein you know
rolled in there and we deployed
um we deployed out to a place called
r-r-a-r-a-r out way out west we were
completely separate from the ground war
we went out there actually to go after
those scuds being shot into israel to
keep israel out of the war if you
remember back then they were threatening
to put their own
soft elements in and of course the
coalition the
syrians were part of that so the arabs
you know
didn't want anything didn't want the
israelis involved
so that was our mission again it was
durant walcott
me and you know several others briley
you know probably wasn't there
and we were flying we had four birds two
would go up
and do a little hunt and the other two
were qrf for the ground elements doing
uh ground recce up there and uh
attacking i mean it was awesome really
really tough flying
um i'm crashed on one of my first
flights bounced off the desert floor
how's that happen well we were doing up
we were doing a little rehearsal
in saudi before we went up there and i
mean
you get out of town there it is black i
mean there's no ambient light your nods
are just you know that sparkle you get
when you can't i mean
you're just like oh these things working
you know
um so we had infilled the dapps we were
our original mission is we were going to
put in an op so we had two guys
in the back and once they the heavy
birds landed with their mobility vehicle
their vehicles
we were gonna you know cover them but
then land you know out
off their flanks and drop off these two
dudes that were going to just sort of be
an op
form while they were getting their
vehicles ready for movement
and so we had dropped these dudes off
and be browned out like i've never
browned out before you know it was just
it was horrible we were climbing out and
the other guy was on the controls and i
may head over in the cockpit
trying to punch up something on this
navigation system because gps was brand
new
and the crew chief who i'm still very
close with i've promoted him a couple
times since then yells out
check altitude and like i got a fleer
screen
you know in front of me with a what we
call rad out or radar altimeter which is
absolute altitude over the ground it's
not a
mean sea level it is how far you are
until you hit the ground
and it said zero and i just reached over
with one hand and pulled up on the
collective and as we smacked the ground
and came up in this cloud of dust
and bent the antennas on the bottom of
the airplane split the tail wheel room
in half
i mean it was i mean i couldn't even
talk for like 30 seconds and i look over
the other guy i'm like
dude what the hell he goes well i
couldn't see
i was like were you going to tell me
that we were underground i mean what was
the plan here you know because we just
cheated death you know and we had i had
several close calls over there probably
any time
more than i've had not directly enemy
related was
you know those dust storms you'd hit
those things up in western iraq which
were
just fierce so it was just biblical
those things
i remember those biblical storms where i
was looking going
this is straight out of the bible
there's a freaking
sand is coming and it's crazy i mean and
i mean and it's violent i mean when it
hits you it's just like i mean it's like
a tsunami
coming at you i mean i mean i know
you're yeah i can exactly picture what
you're looking at that
churn at the bottom and there's coming
at you and you're like
oh [ __ ] man we're gonna have to redo the
windows after this you know
it was bad yeah so what were the
profiles like so what were the profiles
like for those ops that you were doing
out looking for scud missiles
in the in the iraqi desert so we'd go up
there you know we had ground elements up
there
and we'd fly up there and we get
sometimes we get some intel
because there was you know the before
they launched a scud there was certain
things that would happen in advance of
that
and i think i got the nomenclature right
but they had an entree radar which was a
meteorological radar and that thing
would come up a few hours before
it masked and do a 360 sweep get a bunch
of atmospheric data to plug in
because i mean the scuds weren't really
guided i mean they weren't you know
it wasn't like hey we're going to hit
this building it wasn't like that
they had a target in mind but it was a
ballistic solution
so we you know we'd see that thing come
up and in fact one night we were up
there and the rivet joint or whatever
called us and said hey we got a we got
you know we got a hit on this
entry radar and i was chalk two flying
off of walcott
um and sure enough in this little wadi
this truck was sitting down there like a
looks like a combo truck with a big box
fan on it and a mast
and i mean we smoked that dude i mean we
came in and
in fact we got so close uh the lead bird
got so close when they were shooting
they got a secondary off the truck
and it shattered the windshield and uh
co-pilot they said every time they got
over 100 knots the windshield started
caving in so he flew with one foot up
there holding the windshield out we were
going back into
i mean it was it was cool uh so we you
know shot that we had some scuds and
there's a lot of debate to this day if
you google it you'll see
pictures of them um that they were
probably decoys
but they stopped shooting after that i
mean we basically they quit
shooting within a week of us going up
there and so we were all over them
you know our missions were five six
hours long we had to get ox fuel tanks
strap cargo strapped to the floor just
uh
just to make it up that far
dang um
that one didn't last very long either no
i mean for us it started pre like i
didn't even know the war
started except that we had a 10k
loop around the airfield that we go run
and i remember i went out there was a
little sign on an easel
out there or something that said you've
got to run with your gas mask on your
hip which of course you know
again i'm a first lieutenant i'm like
you know really i mean come on that's a
pain in the ass
and that was and i learned later i said
the war started
now uh a funny story uh i was out on my
first mission flying
and uh you can thank your brethren in
the navy on this one
um the other crews were were uh
sitting in the air terminal at this rr
airfield
and in the middle of night boom you know
a uh
a missile comes in you know and
everybody it wasn't it was
it wasn't enough like a bomb but it was
a missile
and everybody's looking and they thought
it was a chemical attack so you know
everybody's you know [ __ ] and elbows
antropine you know everybody's putting
their mass on and all that
but what had happened is is all nav all
navigational aids are supposed to be
shut off
and they had forgot and left a tack in
on uh
you know a digital distance and an ea
6 was coming back going back to the red
sea
now keep in mind we're 35 miles inside
of saudi i mean it's not like
you know we're right on the border and
this dude lets one of those harm
missiles go
and it comes in and you know those
things are like a giant shotgun shell
they get to a certain point and then it
just
opens up and it's like a bunch of
buckshot goes in and takes out the radar
and that's what it was
in fact i i don't think i still have it
but i had a piece of the you know
u.s navy on the canard on it you know
so our only attack was from an ea6 off
of a carrier and a reds
and and did you notice i mean the
mindset
how many how many pilots or how much
experience did you bring from panama and
now you're doing kind of
more operations or was it like hey we're
still we're still feeling pretty green
at this
um you know we certainly i think the
tension
and the anticipation we were getting
used to that you know from panama
of course the environment was completely
different this you know
panama was basically urban really i mean
for the most part
um the challenge the flying was much
more difficult on desert storm for sure
but remember we'd had um prime chance
right
operating off the barges we'd had just
cause now myself and
that was pretty much the norm we'd all
sort of been involved in that and now
this is our sort of our third gig for
that current generation
so i think there was a sense of
confidence there maybe a little
overconfidence
um you know i i don't i wish i would
have got more
time flying in the desert in those kind
of conditions i mean that was
like that was definitely a different
level than i'd ever
experienced before and humbling
so yeah you know planning wise we were
good we knew what we needed to do
gunnery wise we were good probably
environmentals were our biggest
challenge
just those like you said those sand
storms you see one of those things
coming i mean you're like
mommy you know i mean it's like you know
this is not going to end well
you know you get you get done with that
where's your next
where'd you go after that so we got out
of uh we got back from desert storm
and uh this is when i went to this you
know then
down and said hey i want you would you
can i was supposed to go fly with the
marines fly cobras at yuma
as an instructor pilot down there that's
where i was going to go
and then down he said no i want you to
go to hurlburt
to fly with air force special ops
commander's exchange pilot let's start
you know let's start combining you guys
you're a catfield to mccoy's out there
so um i that's where i went i went
through
um kirtland air force base out in new
mexico
you know to go through the air force
version of the 60 qualification course
and then i went to uh 55th special ops
squadron
and uh i mean loved it man it was you
know i was i'd never air refueled before
i'd never done you know and they
it's just a completely different
approach to aviation than
the army has i mean uh
and i led that flew there for four years
and uh you know flew my butt off ended
up being an instructor pilot there
and uh just really and you were still
flying 60s though yeah
because they they wanted me to they
ideally i would have transitioned over
to 53
yeah the problem was it was just one of
those
military things it was a year-long
course so they had done a
permanent change of station to get me
into kirtland and then another permanent
changes station to get back to hurlburt
and nobody wanted to pay for that so i
went there
on temporary duty for four months and i
mean i i'd already had 2 000 hours in
the blackhawk i mean
what this wasn't you know like rocket
science to me you know so
i sort of went through the course pretty
quick i just had to learn air force regs
you couldn't convince them hey if
somebody can just show me how to turn on
this 53 i got it i actually knew how to
start it
but you know the air force has like
these you know they're
they have a lot more regs regulations
and stuff that you got to learn in the
army
it's like much less what was it so you
said the
the view on aviation was different what
else was different
um the culture is a little different i
mean there are great guys there you know
i mean the current jsoc commander scott
howell was in my sister squadron the
current air force special ops command
jim slife
and now they're both their three stars
they were we were like running mates
over there you know
um you know the air force
and the navy with the exception of the
seal community are really
platform-centric right they man a
platform the navy mans a ship the air
force mans and aircraft
the army and the marines and you know
and the seals
we equip the soldier or the sailor
or the marine so it's a different
it's a different mindset there and i
don't mean i would i'm not implying for
a second that they're not
good at their job but you know they're
you know they value that platform i mean
when i was a 160th commander
i lost three aircraft in a week i had
two chinooks land hard and rip the gear
off one had to be blown in place it was
way up in the hindu kush the other we
stripped it down in a 53 the marines
slung it out for us and the third was on
a day mission in the helmand
then got hit with an rpg and crashed
i mean you know i think in the air force
you to get relief for that
you know in the army i never even got a
call
i mean i had to report it up you know
standard op rep kind of stuff
but i think you know uh the army's just
hated jack fatalities and we didn't you
know that we lost you know
probably i don't know 100 million
dollars worth of aircraft
but we didn't have a fatality and again
it's just a different
you know and the other thing about us is
we only exist to support the guy on the
ground
i mean the 160th army aviation isn't a
you know isn't strategic air power right
it's tactical
you know we only exist to support it so
that's our mindset
you know the pilots are the a lot of the
warrants i mean a good percentage of
them were former green berets i had some
former seals bobby moore
uh was in the 160 with me a former seal
a lot of rangers in there
so there's a great empathy for the guy
on the ground right
and i think and that's just our culture
yeah when i had this guy colonel matt
jackson who was a
a huey pilot in vietnam they sent
5 000 hueys to vietnam 3 200 of them
were lost in combat
oh yeah oh yeah i know lots of guys that
were shot down
we and we were talking and i i i j
you know he said well the huey cost i
don't know a couple hundred thousand
dollars back then i said well how much
is a blackhawk
and he goes i don't know maybe 500 000
and i was like
i don't know if that's right sir but
it's like 20 million
right yeah well one of ours is about 23.
um i think you could probably and uh-60
mike is somewhere between
15 and 20 million somewhere around there
i would suspect
they're not throwing those things away
no but they you know but again
i mean i when i was the 160th commander
at the time
i was told this and i can't prove it but
i'm pretty sure it's true
we had more casualties from any 06 level
command
in soft we'd had more than anyone
anything about we had red wing we'd had
a bunch of those
and um and you know but it didn't stop
us i mean we
we never changed i mean we just kept we
got better
right right learn but we like yeah we
lost a lot of aircraft and a lot of
people um
[ __ ] on red wings we lost you know we
had the qrf was eight seals and we had
eight 160th guys on there
yeah um so you come home
you're now so now it's like 1991 we're
about to enter the
the kind of the dry years yeah go to go
to
you know afsock air force special ops
command from there till 96.
this is where you meet your wife yeah
she was a uh the squadron intel officer
and you know of course like she couldn't
figure you out what happened i don't
know she's like you know who
is the you know best looking dude most
manly dude here
clearly you know it was me you know i
mean i'm a total chick magnet uh
and uh you know but we end up yeah we
end up getting married
and then uh i went to a classified
assignment from there
and um and she we'd already had one kid
and then she went
uh we you know so it was one of those
dual military which is tough and then
when she got pregnant with our second
she uh
she elected get out and you know
and i'm grateful because we ended up
having you know three boys total
and i mean she gets all the credit in
the world for raising them because i
mean her
her deal was hey you go out and play
captain america i'll
take care of the family here so i
remained indebted to her
uh and very respectful of her because
she would have been
at least a colonel in my opinion you
know you know you see a young
officer you know who's got it who's not
going to go far
and who is and she was clearly one of
those that was going to go far
so you get how long were you at this
classified assignment for
uh let's see six years
i did uh a year at navy uh newport
okay that's where i met colin green we
were next door neighbors
and uh so i did that and from 96
to then i went back to the 160th
and was um exo of first battalion and
then ended up commanding a couple years
later so when september 11th goes down
you're in newport going to war college
or something
no i was in budapest
on an exercise when it happened
um we were over there doing a uh you
know it was one of those i think it was
like a loose nuke kind of thing you know
exercise and that's where i was
and then you know a few a few weeks
later i was deployed
you know i won't go into the deal but i
was deployed into pakistan and then
basically you know the world changed for
all of us after that
you know so when when you started doing
missions when you
when did you get back to the 160th then
i got back to the 160th
in june
of it was right around father's day of
o2 and then you know
i took over as the executive officer of
first of the 160th
which is you know the the biggest
battalion there and that's where i grew
up
and then we ended up you know a few
months later two months later i was in
afghanistan did back two back-to-back
tours and then we invaded iraq
how long were your tours over there um
back then we were doing i was doing
about
i did 60 days was back for 30 days i
went back for another 60 days
and then i came back because we had an
alert package so you had to mod
you had to have that ready to go so
when i wasn't forward i was back sitting
on alert and then i ended up in iraq and
may
so what kind of ops were you running in
afghanistan were you were you flying as
the xl
yeah oh yeah yeah it was uh it was
it was fun now afghanistan i mean that's
some challenging flying right over there
i mean you know that that you know that
place is like they don't call it the
rooftop of the world for nothing
i mean i i was very you know my
fond is saying and i still say it you
know if you compare iraq to afghanistan
the enemy in iraq is the enemy it's the
insurgents right i mean the terrain is
except for those you know biblical dust
storms over there i mean it's not very
challenging terrain you know
it's usually not very it's usually
predictable too yeah it's going to be
hot
hot yeah in the wintertime it's going to
be cold but it's pretty it's pretty
predictable yeah
but afghanistan i mean you know europe
at the highest altitudes i mean
everybody's running on the little birds
were essentially worthless over there
you know if they were carrying anything
and the chinooks ended up being the
heavy lifter for us to
insert ops up and you know way up into
hindu kush i mean blackhawks couldn't
even do it
so very very challenging flying there in
the early days you know they were
launching out of k2
out of karshikanabad in uzbekistan going
north into
so was it like when you're flying at
that altitude in a helicopter is it like
you're driving on
on like wet pavement where you just
don't get the reactions that you would
normally get
yeah i mean it depends on the altitude
the aircraft is not as responsive but
where
where you really pay the price is if you
get when you're doing an approach in
there i mean you got to closely manage
your power
or you're going to get in trouble if you
let momentum develop on that descent in
the approach
i mean you don't have the power to go
around you know you're committed
regardless of the enemy situation so
it's just
really you're just very very limited
on the uh on on power and options up at
altitude so you know
i remember flying missions up 14
15 000 feet so you got to be on o2
with 47's and there you know their
allowable load was like eight guys in a
chinook
i mean usually it's plus or minus a ton
in those things right i mean you know
just keep packing them in i've seen 100
rangers in a chinook before
and you're down to eight eight when you
guys knew
did you have any time to say hey we
better go start flying
you know around the rocky mountains nope
just figured later we did
later we'd start prepping we go out in
fact we lost an airplane at mount
massive colorado guys training up to go
in there
i lost four guys i was a commander at
the time but in the initial days
no nothing because you know it was a
come as you are deal
so do you know i just knowledge that you
know
like okay well we're at altitude this is
gonna suck yeah
well i mean you do the performance
planning right so you get you understand
what the aircraft can and most
more importantly can't do at those
altitudes so
but you're you know you're sort of in
denial at those numbers you know
i mean i never thought i'd say eight
guys in a chinook
plus you had to deal with the brown out
that dust was just
really really bad worse in the southern
parts down in
helmand and down in those areas around
kandahar
less so up in uh you know up in the
hindu kush mountains up in the north but
you know i mean it was
brutal flying brutal and
so you when you first got over there
your first deployment what's your op
temple like
um so i got over there the first time i
was there
i think september of 02
or august of 02 through maybe october
or maybe november i can't remember but
um
we did a fair amount of missions and um
and then you know i the last next time i
went over there i think i was there in
january now i left december i remember i
left december right before christmas
30 days to the day i was right back in
the same crappy little tent
up there at bagram you know with rain
water i mean it was just
water running through it and everything
uh and then from
january through march because you know
they were spinning up at the latter part
of that to go into iraq right
we were don't they got the word we're
going in and um
we didn't do much i mean because weather
was really crappy i did a couple of
missions
uh some pretty challenging ones way way
up in the uh
in some areas that were very tricky
for aviation in fact i one i was so high
in uh
in a place called cantigua that we
couldn't have any fire support
i mean the airplanes wouldn't perform so
i just elected to
stay on the x right we infilled and i
got the ground force commander so give
me a couple guys cover our blind spots
and uh we're just going to go to ground
ida while you guys clear and get
whatever you're getting and then hop
back in and we'll
normally you know you know the deal we
come in we'd land drop off and then
split
we did we just stayed and you know
pulled the engines back because i didn't
i didn't want to
it took us two hour turn to go get gas
down the hill and come back and i didn't
want to leave them up there for that
long so we said hey we'll just hang out
how long are you on the ground for
about 45 minutes to an hour it wasn't
that bad
it was cold though i mean it was
freezing snow and everything else up
there
it was like i said february or something
how at what point did you uh notice that
people were just
like this is what we're this is what
we're doing this is the new reality
you know when i talked to you you know
you were talking about i was talking
about the mindset you know when you did
panama and then you did desert storm and
you
you're not quite there yet you know
you're yeah you're not quite there yet
and then you know we were talking
earlier uh my first deployment to iraq
it's like oh
we're doing another you know yeah we're
doing another op this is just what we're
doing it's just like
becomes normal yeah um
i think that really you know there was
the op
tempo the operational tempo in
afghanistan
wasn't that bad just because of the
terrain
and the planning and we didn't have all
the isr back then you know we didn't
have all that
all the you know the tools to give us
good situational awareness on targets
like
we ended up having in iraq where i saw
that it was
we really became just sort of another
day at the office was in iraq so i went
over in may
and i'll never forget my boss this is
may of 03.
so my boss you know they had punched up
there around
march or so i think you know they did
that big win into baghdad international
airport
i came in and i you know the xo is sort
of the
you know he's the guy in charge of all
the staff and
you know logistics and all that kind of
stuff and my boss said hey come over
here we're
we're going to be out of here in 30 days
i just want you to make sure we got
property accountability and you get all
your stuff and get out
and i was like you know i mean i hadn't
been to iraq so i'm like
sign me up chief i'm in you know yeah so
i showed up there you know of course you
know 30 days
never happened but man i mean the best
time i mean we did we did some
ops uh that were just incredible i mean
the op temple was really really high i
mean we were banging targets we did
an op um it's been in several magazines
op
reindeer it was a bunch of bunch of
foreign fighters had gathered they were
getting ready to split up and attack
coalition bases with teams of three
and uh we got the intel on and went in
with a half gaff
kind of thing you know helicopter saw
force for the audience and ground to
solve force on each side of this wadi
and i mean it was it was game on i mean
it went on we
fought for about two hours killed about
a hundred of them
a young ranger took an rpg below the
knee
uh you know we casual vacuum i'm still
in touch with him matt waters he's up in
tacoma as a cop right now
freaking out yeah he is he's stud i mean
uh second range of italian bicode 275
was the unit
i mean i was a mission of a lifetime you
know i was i was uh
air mission commander right in the jump
seat of a 47 tracer
coming in underneath the tracer fireman
it was awesome in fact i was
the tracer file was coming out my left
side you know of course your chest
plate's
meant to protect your chest i was
loosening up my side strap
and slid it around this way like i'm
going to get clipped it's going to be
over here you know
but just a great mission ah six is just
crushing them and it was a fight went on
for a couple hours
did a lot of engagements shooting them
fours out of the side of the because the
rangers were so close to the enemy
that we didn't want to use mini guns
because they're ricochet so we just
hover in there and the
ah six guys would take them out with uh
m4s and peck twos and all that
so it was a good that was the remains
the best mission i ever did it was
awesome
and so this is st this is in like that
was june 11
2003 got it yeah and this is now
now we're getting into legit op tempo
this is what we're doing
reload get jocked up again we're going
out tomorrow here's the next target
it went from that till you know you
flash forward now a couple years later
right prior to the surge and we were
running we'd be running
seven eight ops a night i mean i'd have
those big screen tvs and isr tracking
multiple ops
out out of uh blood and i mean it was
just
non-stop so you went for 30 days how
long did you end up staying for
well he said it was going to be 30 days
so i left in august
so i was there about 90 or so and then i
came back was back for two months and
then i went over there for christmas and
spent you know another
60 and then i i you know a lot of guys
can tell you how many times they're over
there i don't i have no idea i just lost
track i mean
that was just you know it was back and
forth back and forth and
at what point did you go were you axel
the whole time or did you eventually
fleet up and
no so the army does it a little
different and
so i was exo from 2002
to 2004 and then to command
first to the 160th it's a special board
called the special mission unit board
that meets
and you have to have commanded another
05 level command before that
so i got selected and went over to
germany and commanded for two years over
in germany which was you know a great
i wouldn't call it a breather you know
commands command but
i didn't deploy and so i you know the
family and i you know
drank a bunch of heffies and ate a bunch
of chocolate and you know
my wife's like man this camera makes us
look fat oh yeah that's definitely yeah
and so you did that tour and and then i
got picked up to go back to one 160
and uh which was uh
0 6 to 08 and then the guy that was
supposed to take the regiment
opted to retire instead for personal
reasons
and they i they did a special they
i my name went in to command you know to
be
considered for commanding the regiment
at the 0-6 level so i did
i came right out of first the 160th
moved my box i loved me stuff
and walked down the hallway and took
over the regiment so i was in command
six straight years dang yeah it but
you know you don't realize how tired you
are my wife's like yeah you're smoked
i'm like no i ain't smoked i'm like a
little energizer bunny here i'm ready to
keep going
when you when you went back as battalion
commander so what was that so now it's
2006 what was your most your focus
iraq so we were totally engaged in iraq
so
myself my xo and my opso we were on a
three
you know so it was one of the three of
us was downrange as a task force
commander forward so
i was totally committed we were totally
committed to iraq we did some other
stuff we had some stuff in south america
pop up where we deployed
operationally there was you know some
hostage stuff going on down there
but we were completely mainly we were
focused and i was really worried about
keeping the team together remember we've
been in a fight now this is
for several years so chronic fatigue was
an issue for me i was really worried the
wheels were going to come off so a lot
of my focus was
keeping you know making sure i'm
monitoring the players
and uh and making sure that we're you
know doing the best and i got my crystal
there
who is you know you know aviation is the
pacing item over there so there
they want more and more and more so you
know and i always i told my chrysalis
several years later my job was to try to
meet your requirements but
you know make sure the unit survived and
we didn't you know we didn't start
losing people to
accidents and things like that and we
lost a lot of folks but all you know
combat related i did have
you know i lost one bird on mount mass
of colorado we lost four
doing high altitude training for
preparing to go into afghanistan when i
was a regimental commander so we
certainly had our
share of accidents but but overall i
thought it was
you know it was less than what i was
expecting
yeah you wouldn't think that when when
you know after after desert won right
and they formed jsoc
yeah they weren't trying to put together
uh a
a bunch of units that would be on
sustained combat operations around the
world
right this was not the plan no it was
hostage it was short
intense ops and then you know and then
you know
back home to refit and retrain and reset
right it wasn't this so so taking this
group of
people and just going oh yeah you're
going to go to war
oh yeah it's going to last about 20
years which is what happened
it's still yeah i mean you know it's
wrapping up there in afghanistan now but
you know
the ones you know i always joked when
i'd talk to my
counterparts i'd say you know we've
deployed we're still waiting for that
redeployment order
you know because we stay we're staying
over there so aviation is always there
even the ground units are coming in and
out you know the
they had more of a predictable cycle
right you got your two-year cycle at nsw
and there's jorts and other cycles that
the other units use
but because aviation is high demand and
low density
i mean you got to spread the peanut
butter a lot thinner i mean we were
rotating
all the time you know we had two c5
c-17s a month coming out of uh
campbell to replace you know combat
damaged aircraft and bring aircraft back
for maintenance and then rotate people
in on them
are they going to try and make special
operations
bigger it certainly doesn't seem that
way
no you know i mean i had the rand guys
come in and see me when i was the
regimental commander and said hey
there's enough demand for a second
regiment
and i said i'm sure there is but there's
no way the army could sustain that i
mean we're a talent thief
from army aviation already you know you
don't get assigned to the 160th right as
a pilot you
you have to be you have to apply and go
through an assessment process and get
selected
you know you know and there's a the
brigades pay a price for that you know
the aviation brigades in the army
they're losing
solid folks now the nation gains from
that
but you know if we doubled the size of
that there's no way
no way they could sustain that uh it's
just the nature of the beast you know
i mean we're gonna be you know we're
gonna be the
we're going to be forward and we're
going to have to operate at a different
op tempo than our
than the ground forces we support and
it's just a fact of life i accepted a
long time ago i understood
the realities behind it and never push
back
because at the end of the day you know
i'm not going to leave you in an hlz
and that you know and i'm not you know
if you need combat power and we can
provide it if it's physically possible
we're going to do it
so from a leadership perspective that's
like full commander's intent right there
like hey we are going to support these
guys on the ground
no matter what it takes exactly and you
know your greatest strength carries over
to be your greatest weakness
i'm sure that some of my senior officers
would say that i was
pretty aggressive in that and
and they would be accurate you know i
but
it was it was you know burned into my
psyche early on that hey that's why we
exist
so and i don't care if the ground force
commander is an e6 or an o6
i don't care doesn't matter i don't care
what uniform he's wearing
you know what service he's in i mean if
if they're our responsibility to support
them then we're going to meet that
responsibility no matter what
and i you know i take a lot of pride in
that but we also you know
we can accept more risk in a 160 because
we have a special assessment selection
process to get our pilots
and our pilots stay with us for
i'm not saying forever but i'll give you
an example
when you saw the movie black hawk down
and you see that little bird landing in
the intersection and they pull out the
two wounded operators that get shot on
they were on super six one
so one of the pilots in there was a guy
carl meyer
who i went through green platoon with in
88 early 88 february
that happened in 93 right so he'd
already been in the unit
five years he retired like two and a
half years ago
or not even two years ago it's from the
unit yeah and he was still flying mh6
assault birds that whole time so
that's kind of freaking awesome that'd
be like you being on a team i mean
you're going back into a building yep
been there done that
got 100 of these t-shirts you know that
knowledge and that
competency and proficiency that you get
out of being able to retain those pilots
what that really translates to
is you know i'm willing we're willing to
push the envelope
uh ops because we know we have that
talent and we rely on those
warrants you know primarily
um to you know make good decisions um
and and to push the envelope we had an
op up in
mosul area and uh they went long right
this is
you know ground guys do an ssc it went
long and i had to extend them beyond
like 18 hours flight time which is a
long time
and they were taxing back into one of
the airfields up there to get gas and
one of the mh-60s
clipped the side of a hangar with its
rotor blades and it was clearly from
fatigue
and you know when we did the accident
investigation i told my boss
at three star i said i own that and they
said what do you mean i said look i know
we got to learn lessons from this but
the fact is i extended them
well beyond their day and this was you
know they weren't flying you know
supplies back and forth they're doing
combat the guys were tired
i took the risk so i owned that
you know i mean we we pushed them and we
paid a price i mean it's a small price
frankly and i would have done it all
over again
but so costs a couple hundred grand for
a rotor blade
but you know what what leadership
lessons do you have when you look at
yourself as a platoon commander in
charge of eight birds
to battalion commander so
first of all you know i i believe
that leadership is a learned skill not a
natural skill and that those
the skill sets required at different
levels change
right so as a pl a platoon leader right
it's direct leadership
jocko follow me you know um we're going
here we're doing that
right and you and your troop
um but as you get more senior
now you've got these layers of
bureaucracy in between you
right and you know think back to when
you're a young
0102 down in the teams and you got you
know that
ancient dude who's an o5 up there right
and it was clearly clueless because
everybody who's above you is clueless
right that's a
you know common hell belief by all and
and you know i just kept learning you
know so when i was remember i told you i
was really worried about chronic fatigue
and
morale and you know families or fran
because of what's
this op tempo so that
uh warrant i was telling you about carl
meyer who was a little bird driver and
his
wife cindy who i'm still friends with to
this day
one day i was walking around the hangar
and and she said you know you ought to
go spend some time with these young
troops
you know because they want to hear from
the battalion commander what's happening
you know
and it really resonated with me so i
blocked out
and this is a small leadership technique
but it was very effective for me i
blocked out two hours a week
and i went and i never told anybody
where i was going and it wasn't an
inspection right i wasn't coming over
there and saying well nick why do you
got a croakie on your freaking
sunglasses it was more you know
just to sort of get a bird's eye you
know a ground view of how things are
going
and you know at first it was quite a you
know quite a dust up you know i'd walk
into
you know littlebird company and you know
the guys are like what the hell are you
doing
down here well i said i'm the commander
of this outfit i'd like to think i could
come down here if i want
but over time they realized there was no
threat i made sure i never chewed
anybody's ass when i was down there it
wasn't you know it wasn't about that if
i saw something particularly egregious
i go back to the exo and say hey go down
to you know owens hangar and police
those dudes up
i'm the good cop you're the bad cop kind
of thing but what i would do is spend
time with troops and it was very low
threat so i get them around sit around
and talk with them
hey you know what can i do to make the
unit better
you know what do you think about are you
going i was a big pusher of off-duty
education because of my personal
background i
knew how you know how powerful it was
and
so i'd always encourage them about that
and i'd look for easy wins low hanging
fruit you know like if there was
something going on that needed to be
fixed but they were just struggling
through you know multiple
forms and triplicate to get some crap
done or something
then i would short circuit that and you
know i've shared this before with other
folks but
one day i was in the engine shop and we
were turning aircraft
from combat damage and you know
maintenance i mean it was
really we could barely keep up with what
we needed to have downrange
and i relied on these you know young 18
19 year old kids that were bore scoping
engines
and you know doing stuff that they had
no idea of
probably their criticality to us
maintaining the right number of aircraft
to deploy but
i clearly knew so i you know i come into
their little engine shop this particular
time and i call them all in you know
round you know in fact uh
cindy meyer used to call it uncle clay's
story hour you know so i'd sit in there
and you know chat with them but i'd
always ask them hey
you know what what could i do you know
what can i do to
to make the unit better what can i do to
make your job easier
and this one young e4 said to me
you know sir i maxed my army physical
fitness test the apft
you know an army lingo and he said but i
got to go out and run with like the
slowest people out there in formation
run you know it's a bunch of
garbage you know why don't we have an
incentive pt program which is pretty
common you know you score above a
certain
score and you you know you can sort of
do your own thing
and uh i said that's a good question let
me get back to you and that was about
one in the afternoon so i walked back up
to the headquarters got on
email sent email out to the first
sergeants and said hey do you have an
incentive pt program
if you know if not why not and should we
have one
and they basically all wrote back and
said
yeah look we've been in combat we just
that kind of stuff has sort of fallen
off our radar
we should have one so you know i got
with the tsar major
typed up a policy you know the agita
more accurately typed it up i signed it
and said if you get above whatever a 290
it's a possible score 300
you can pt on your own i walked right
back down about two hours later to that
same dude you know specialist i don't
know i don't remember his name
handed him the policy letter and said
hey
thanks you were right we should have
done this it just fell off our radar
you've you know you have changed
battalion policy here is our
incentive pt program you know of course
that kid crowed about that
you know and i mean six months later i'm
hopping on a c-17
pulling a pump over to iraq and this
sergeant you know as i'm crawling into
my fart sack you know getting ready to
take my ambien go to la la land and he
uh
he said hey sir i just want to tell you
you know that kid still just
brags about changing policy but you know
little things like that
the force responds to that right they
know you give a damn in which i do
and um you know they know they got a
voice
of course i didn't you know you know why
can't we have you know
women in the barracks you know blah blah
blah you know like you know why can't we
run a prostitution ring out here well
you know they're not going to get
everything you know but
you know i i tried to you know make sure
they understood they were appreciated
and uh you know that doesn't mean i
don't hold the standard right i mean you
know you got to earn the right to be in
these units every day
and it ain't a job for life but i also
need
you know they they should have faith and
confidence in a chain of command we're
going to do the best we can
and be transparent as we can and you
know i think it worked pretty well
how about when you uh elevated up to
then regimental commander
a little harder right and it got
exponentially harder as a
general officer um but again now the
bureaucracy increases more and now you
know as a battalion commander i'm down
and in right i mean i'm
i'm dealing with my boss a regimental
commander
but really my focus is combat right in
my unit
as the regimental commander at the time
i also had a humongous budget you know i
was the most expensive
06 level command in the army by orders
of magnitude
by orders of magnitude we were also
geographically dispersed i have a
battalion up at fort lewis washington
4-160 i got a battalion in
savannah georgia three 160. i got two
battalions uh
operational battalions of fort campbell
plus a training battalion plus an r d
outfit i've got guys all over the world
and i'm you know i'm an o6 so most of my
time that was the big changes now it's
up and out
now i'm protecting my budget right like
i'm the best looking woman at the frat
party i mean everybody wants to go out
with me they're trying to steal my cash
you know so i'm you know and i'm an 06
and i'm dealing with geos you know um so
it was much more
resource stuff i'm looking two or three
ridgelines down what do i need to do to
make sure that we're
adequately resourced and we remain you
know quoting general or admiral mcraven
we may not comparative but maintain that
comparative advantage over our adversary
so that was my focus
that was the biggest difference it
wasn't down and it wasn't combat anymore
it was taking care of the regiment
down the road and making sure that they
had what they needed and that was really
this i mean that was a great training
ground for being a
flag officer because that's exactly what
you know when you were aiding for
mcguire i bet most of his stuff was
resource stuff right yeah
oh yeah absolutely yeah yeah he was um
that's what that's what he that's what
he did that's what you do
you know manchester united money title
and
well i'm sure you know the navy the seal
teams don't always do well in that
category so it's rough sometimes
um and like you said especially when
you're going up you know against the air
force and just the the amount of
platforms that they have is
freaking rough yeah because they need so
much money
for each one of those platforms it's
it's like way more expensive
than a boat yeah yeah much more and i
think now though we're now where we got
our we sort of got our swim lanes right
so we you know we do we're rotary wing
that's what we do we do have
unmanned we got uh gray eagles which are
basically a predator you know improved
predator
um but you know we're very focused on
what we do afsox very focused on what we
do
and you know going back to my tenure at
afsoc as a young captain those
relationships
that i built with those air force guys
really paid huge dividends later right
like
i'm a personal friends with the air
force special ops commander jim slife
you know i mean he was the chief of
staff at socom when i was a three
you know we had a we have a personal
friendship scott howell out of fort
bragg we're personal friends i mean when
i call them and say something it's
there's a trust factor that goes both
ways
and it's with numerous other so i mean
that made my life a lot easier and
really broadened my
sort of horizons as an officer realize
that you know hey it really does take a
joint force to get this done
and understand the different
perspectives you know
yeah we i was really my last deployment
was in was in ramadi and
just i mean yeah we wouldn't have been
able to do anything without the army in
the marine corps
to have our back qrf yeah all that stuff
qrf kazavac just every everything that
we needed
we needed from those guys they needed to
support us and we needed to support them
it was just an
awesome relationship um
so you get done with that tour yeah and
then what's next so i had been deferred
from the war college like three times
you know i was supposed to go
you're supposed to go be 406 command as
you know you know but i never
went i was deferred and so i ended up
going after
and i made flag officer while i was in
the war college i mean i didn't get
announced because i had to go through
all the joint credit stuff you have to
do you know
and uh but i ended up deploying to
afghanistan
um as part of uh ntma national training
mission afghanistan and i stood up the
afghan special
mission wing to support their uh afghan
commandos and uh the catehas
wow those dudes and that was another
education so i'm in kabul
um and you know we stood up this fleet
of
this unit of mi 17s and
isr birds u28 sort of you know not with
all the
high-speed kit that you got on an
american bird but fixed-wing isr
platforms
stood up all the units got the funding
through uh
dod and it's still i mean they're still
banging targets to this day i ran into
the unit commander a couple years ago he
was at a
conference here or something we got
caught up but
i mean that was a another real growing
experience right because it's all about
money and i'd have to brief the
pentagon the afghan restock resource
oversight council
you know why did we buy mi-17s and not
american
i'm like well you said we had to be out
here december of 14.
there's no way i can train them on a new
airplane between now and then
so you know i'm all about buying
american but you know
you know the russian the mis how many
birds did they get for their
28 30 30 helicopters
28 were operational the ministers and
everything i always wanted to fly on
them so i
i bought two extra just to take care of
the vip stuff which was a you know we
would you know it was a wicked pain in
my ass but
and then we about i think it was 15
[Music]
uh 15 fixed-wing birds and we were split
across we had a squadron in
uh condues we had a squadron in helmand
and then we had two in kabul and we did
both ct
counterterrorism and counter narcotics
so dea was a player in there and that
was actually
part of the negotiation the dea wanted
to make sure that we were still going to
hit
dea targets so in which we you know i
gave them my personal guarantee you know
we're not going to blow that mission off
it's really not something the military
wants to get into but
you know we we kept that as a primary
mission set for them
who's running training for the afghan
pilots well that was interesting right i
mean trying to find an afghan that can
read
first of all back then because the
schools have been shut down for you know
what 20 years or so
so we had a core of pilots that have
been flying that have been trained by
the russians that were there a few but
not enough
so we ran some of our pilots through um
uae they had some training there that
they go over to uae or by abu dhabi and
they go through i think it was horizon's
flight academy it's probably still there
and then we'd we'd pick them you know
and it was funny because the dea you
know they're like
you know they're very worried
understandably so about insider attacks
right
so they came to me one day and said hey
we got to give these guys a polygraph
and i'm like okay well what are we going
to ask them because i mean everybody
steals there right you know patronage is
part of the deal right you know hey we'd
take my sister to uh you know
condos or whatever here's 20 bucks i
mean that in the middle u.s military
that'd be like you'd be
prosecuted for that over there that's
just normal
so i'm talking to the dea guy and i said
so
you know here's the way i think it needs
to go okay jocko you want to come to the
special mission wing here put on this
little lie detector thing
they actually had a finger thing which i
think was remained
skeptical about that but i said okay
jocko did you steal anything today
the answer is yes did you feel bad about
it and do you promise not to steal
tomorrow
okay year ago you know i mean
it's just a different i mean it's a
different culture yeah you know so we
had to be you know so vetting was a big
thing and then you know the insider
attacks really got
worse you know later in fact one of our
families was a national guard guy
in the sowf that was training with the
rangers he was a guard guy out of utah
brent taylor
shot and killed i mean by an afghan
doing a ruck march pulled out his pistol
and shot the dude but you know that was
a challenge
human it's always human talent right
humans are more important in hardware i
mean
and it's true you know getting the right
guys but
hey listen they right after i left they
hit their did their first nvg
uh you know i think it was to the y or
something mission
down near jpad man i couldn't have been
prouder of those dudes and they you know
i get
feedback you know periodically from
folks that they're still
i mean they're by far the most
successful aviation unit over there
yeah that's outstanding we we had a guy
on this podcast captain ahn who was uh
who's a south vietnamese pilot and flew
sog missions
in awesome i mean just freaking epic but
he got he got trained over here
yeah you know fort rucker probably right
he got trained over here and
then he went back over and um man if you
get a chance
listen to that one he's major on major
uh he was a captain and then he
eventually made major
his one of his well his last mission he
was
got shot um birds going down
he's trying to save the bird as he's
going down
everything's on fire the uh i guess the
yolk
what what what what is he holding he's
holding the cyclic yeah so he's holding
the cyclic
everything's too hot for him to hold on
to he can't hold on to it
so he's got his hands up by his chest
and he sees the bird's gonna crash if he
doesn't just grab hold of these controls
so he just freaking reaches down grabs
hold the controls gets the
gets the pilot gets the aircraft to the
ground
uh his hands are just burned beyond
anything and he goes to undo his seat
belt and his
fingers fall off he goes to undo
but he manages to get it off you know
hooked on something and get his seatbelt
off
goes to open the door his the rest his
other hand
fingers fall off um
eventually gets out of the aircraft and
gets away um gets back to friendlies
ended up going to hospital loses both of
his hands
um you know carries on for a little
while the war
the war ends ends up in a in a communist
prison camp
gets you know can't do can't do anything
really i mean he's got he doesn't have
hands
so they eventually just kind of let him
out of the prison camp and he
he goes on multiple escape attempts
trying to get out of there and
eventually he does make it out
makes it to america but um i'll
definitely i'll write that after we're
done i'll write that number down
i'll definitely i just subscribe i'm
gonna yeah i'll definitely listen i'd
love to hear yeah those
those king bee pilots over there um this
is also a guy who was going into a hot
lz where they'd already lost
one or two birds and he says you know he
just takes his
leaves his crew chief there leaves his
co-pilot
he just takes his gunner because he's
like hey we're going in
there's chances aren't looking good i'm
not risking anybody else
we're going nice yeah yeah that's you
don't see that very often
freaking awesome inspiring yeah so you
get that stood up what's what's next on
so then i get i take command of the army
special ops aviation command at fort
bragg
i was the second commander followed the
very capable uh
lieutenant general retired kevin mangum
who was my boss at the regiment i took
over for him there
and really that's a title 10 command
right remember i told you i was focused
up and out as a regimental commander
so the army leadership recognized that
they needed a general officer that sort
of took care of the trained man and
equip stuff and let the regiment really
focus on war fighting
so i did two years there um
[Music]
you know and really it's like a lot of
budget stuff and personnel stuff
then i went to korea as the dcg of the
second infantry division from 14 to 15.
and that was a blast i was going to say
how awesome was that that was i mean
my family my wife had just finished her
master's and was teaching and my kids
one kid was in college the other ones
were in high school so i said you know
hey i'm
you guys i'll do this year and uh
you know i mean other than not having my
family with me i mean i was a pt
machine man i ate you know you know
captain crunch berry and freaking
protein bars and worked out the gym
every day man i mean you know
and dealt with the koreans learned a lot
about you know the village idiot up
north there
kju and uh i mean it was
awesome awesome tour i loved it i loved
korea
loved the people there you know and how
awesome is it that you get to go from
your
entire your career of aviation and then
boom you're deputy commander of the
second infantry division
yeah i mean it was cool i had a great
boss i mean you know
and uh i mean i learned again you know
it's all about the journey right there
is real no destination and leadership
you're just continuing to learn and get
better and you get a lot of failure
around that you know
along the way which makes you better
ultimately
but korea was broadened my stuff first
of all i hadn't really spent much time
in the conventional military except for
that one battalion restaurant in south
you know so i'm like you know they're
giving me some army report about you
know readiness and i'm like
they said so sir clearly you know about
this i was like nope
you don't even know what that acronym
means you know yeah
i'm working without tools here boys so i
need you to step up
you know uh but you come with that sort
of hey we can do this
and you know i took more of a focus on
the human side you know and
you know building the unit and doing a
lot of leader development stuff and
pt and the crap out of them every chance
i got you know
so you know i mean it was it was a blast
that was a one-year tour one year yeah
and then i came back i was the deputy cg
you probably
you know my boss was tovo kendra okay
yeah he was just great
best boss best boss ever yeah so he was
the sigisot of commander when i was in
ramadi and see i was in bilad when you
were over there because i saw
tovo mark irwin was the tf 16 commander
then
who's now the ceo of bardstown bourbon
company by the way i'm not sure how that
skill set translated but he makes some
killers i think i do know how that
translates all good but anyway yeah i
worked for tovo for two years
and uh just under two years loved it
great dude
yeah he get he he gave us such
incredible support
you know to my task unit down there in
ramadi you know
it was a slugfest down there and he knew
it
and he just was awesome was just
outstanding
yeah colin said the same thing um you
know funny story about toy he had a
great sense of humor right you know he's
sort of a
quiet dry sense of humor and so his aide
it was this guy uh carter i won't use
his last name but carter
uh just in case he listens to this
podcast so his the way our office was
laid out is he had an xo was an o5 and
then he had an aide who was an o4
but he worked right outside my desk and
so you know
a great guy mustang like me was ranger
regiment guy
went to west point and then went sf and
you know
just a stud his wife's a doctor in the
air force actually
anyway so we got a mutually antagonistic
relationship you know one-liners
so it started this war between us so uh
my my rto
my communicator was a sf guy
and his wife was the manager of
victoria's secrets in
fayetteville and uh so he was going on
an overseas trip with tovo and tovo had
two knee replacements so every time he
went through tsa checkpoint he got
wanded
so we put a uh we put a pair of like
i don't know size 50 thong uh women's
skivvies inside
of uh of carter's coin bag right then we
put a throwaway on top so like you know
on his
on his day and a half back so he opens
it up he's like oh you think you're
going to get me with these underwear he
doesn't check his coin back
so he goes through the fayetteville
international airport there and uh
tovo's getting wanded the bag goes
through the you know the x-ray machine
of course
you know the tsa one's like hey we got
to check yep yes ma'am no it's my coin
bag right here right in front of toevo
she pulls out those skivvies
and of course he knew it was me behind
you know the master criminal there
so then he starts uh having tovo sign
these like his command photos and
putting them
in a frame like with messages you know
claire i know i'm your mentor and he
loved me
and he put him in my bookcase but i
didn't have the key to get the [ __ ] out
of there right
so i'm like all right so i have my xo
blow up
uh command photo of me like you know the
drop down ceiling tiles you know they're
whatever they're 16 by 16 or something
and i put my picture over and put it
above the ceiling tile above his desk
with like a little note you know for
like three days i'm sitting in my office
and uh
you know waiting for him and all of a
sudden here what the you know
so anyway you know we should have been
more responsible
as you know senior gofos but we weren't
at least i wasn't
you still got to have a good time yeah
oh yeah tovo was definitely the adult
leadership i was the comic relief
throughout
and then what was after that so i went
to the j3
at socom okay yeah that was march of 17
my wife joined me and the kids we had a
you know we had we finished a school
year and then they came down in june
and you know there i uh again i didn't
know what was next i was
39 years at that point or you know
closing in on 40.
trying to figure out if you should make
a career of it well yeah you know i mean
i was still waiting for something to
open up and you know like mcdonald's or
dairy queen or something
um and uh you know and
you know general thomas was the socom
commander at the time
and he's now the chairman of the board
of the special office warrior foundation
and my neighbor
and uh he said hey i want you to you
know i'm thinking about moving you to be
the chief of staff
you know and then let's see what happens
with a potential
third star certainly not not a lock
but you know i uh i started thinking
about that and you know i said hey look
i'll stay if you need me to stay
if you're asking me i think i'm ready to
ready to get out i mean it'll be close
to 41 by the time i
you know punch out and i'm sort of done
you know and uh so he you know was very
gracious and said yeah hey good you
listen you know you got your time on the
rock and i was like yeah like twice over
you know and when i retired there on
mcdill
my youngest who's now just finished up
his sophomore year clemson
was like three months younger than i was
when i joined
you know so you know i go in at 17 and
i'm out at 58.
so you know how did you end up
at you know how did you end up at the um
special
operations warrior well i wasn't on my
radar right i really didn't know what i
was going to do
i figured i'd you know be one of those
you know dudes you know
trying to sell helicopters to somebody
or something
but general brown who you know we
discussed before we went live was
the chairman of the board of the special
ops warrior foundation and
i didn't know exactly what was going on
but i knew that joe mcguire had been
sort of nommed for that to go to
national counterterrorism center i know
that was his last gig when he had
as a deputy i think up there before he
retired
and that was sort of in the works and
they asked me
would you be interested they didn't you
know they would you be interested do you
have any interest in running a
non-profit
and to be honest with you i hadn't
really thought about it you know
and so i um i almost said
no i think you know i'm gonna go i'll do
that later let me go make some money and
then you know then i'll do that
but i thought you know what you know
just take a look i said hey sir you know
this was not the only thing he talked to
me about the conversation was almost
like a little sidebar at the end
i said yeah i'd like to learn more and i
didn't even know it was the sowf
i just knew it was a non-profit because
i was in a running
i was a finalist to be the president of
the citadel at the time which would have
been a cool
you know leader development job right
which i got x out by a four-star
graduate i can't believe it you know
general walters is doing great there but
then that thing came through with uh
for joe mcguire to go up there and i
didn't realize it at the time but he was
a big advocate for me and i remain
uh grateful to him and i ended up taking
over for him i graduated i mean i did my
retirement ceremony august 24th
of 18 and september 1st
i was wearing my little special sowf
shirt
and figuring you know and figuring out
how to panhandle
for money you know so tell us about the
mission um
of the special operations warrior
foundation
so you know the fort the foundation is
just had our 41st anniversary it was
started in desert one when we lost those
eight americans three marines
five airmen left behind seventeen kids
and there was a commitment by the
members of that
task force to take care of those kids so
that's how we started
and we've evolved over time today
we have two primary missions we provide
immediate financial assistance to
severely
wounded ill or injured special ops
personnel
and that comes in the form of an
overnight check for up to 5k
if another organization like navy seal
foundation takes care of
uh their folks and you know we work
together with them in fact i had dinner
with
the director navy seal foundation last
night and her husband
bill and so we do that we overnight
a check to them and that's really put
the dog in the kennel money fly in
your mother to watch the kids so you can
go with your loved one and we also send
them a device called the echo show which
is sort of like an alexa with a video
capability
so they can communicate with their
family from the hospital room they can
stream videos and during covid that's
been a really
big hit that's one mission but our
primary mission
is a very unique approach to educating
the children
of fallen special ops personnel and
the children of all medal of honor
recipients all living
and deceased and non-soft right so we
cover all of them
and our program is we call it cradle to
career it starts in preschool
we fund preschool for up to 8k per year
per child
we fund unlimited tutoring from that
time all the way through college
graduation
we pay for their college visits we bring
our high school kids about 30 a year or
so plus or minus to tampa for a college
prep course called
epic education preparation information
conference
we talk to them about picking a major
picking a school
writing your essay for your common app
financial management study skills time
management
um a lot of leader development stuff
very very effective we pay you know we
pay for all their college and we don't
care if they go to a trade school you
want to be a plumber
you want to be a hair stylist that's
good we'll fund that
if you go to an ivy we'll fund that
there is no
limitation it's your passion and
potential
that'll drive where you go and we're
going to support you all the way through
um we have a mentoring program keep in
mind these are kids in a single parent
home
most likely right and you've been
through it you know the trauma that goes
behind that casualty right that's
that's the real tragedy it's just
unfolding there
and so we have a mentoring program that
starts in eighth grade
with these kids you know hey what do you
want to be when you grow up jocko
you know if i'm your dad and i'm telling
you you're like
yeah you know i'm not listening to you
so we do that and that continues all the
way through helping them
secure internships we pay for study
abroad we pay for internships
we pay a 5k stipend for them to relocate
to do an internship we have a special
needs program
that we got about 25 to 30 kids with
varying degrees of special needs
and i consider special needs kids that
have emotional issues associated with
the loss of their parent not what you
would traditionally call
special needs right because you listen
their
their their their challenges even in the
discipline
are as a result of their parent service
at least in part i would say not that
there's not accountability there because
there is
that's part of it right but we fund that
and you take these kids from preschool
we invest in preschool why because we've
seen that that pays dividends down the
road
last year we had 41 kids graduate
high school 38 went right to college two
joined the military and one took a year
off
well above the national average we had
93 percent of our kids last year
graduate
college on time with a degree and that's
consistent and the numbers just get
better and better and better
and these are kids that are again single
parent home
and it's a great mission today we have
996 kids in the program
the youngest is a just last january was
a year old dustin aard
his father dustin gabriellard was a
sergeant first class and third group
was shot and killed in afghanistan and i
mean
our education counselors who are really
the tip of the spear for us there's six
of them
said he's class of 2042 and we make a
promise
and we say okay hey dustin we got you
all the way through you know you can
count on it we're going to fund that and
that's how we
we do that in accounting and everything
that we're going to fund that through
and you know to see these kids reach
their full potential after
sacrificing for their country which they
didn't necessarily sign up for
i mean to me it's a great calling and uh
you know am i you know making as much
money as i could selling helicopters to
somebody probably not
but i i look forward to coming to work
every day
yeah it's i mean as i started the whole
thing
talking about steve voigt and just
learning that impact that that the
organization
has had on him obviously and
that you know like like i was saying
earlier
i didn't do anything for steve you know
i was his friend yeah but
the fact i didn't do anything um i tried
to serve
the best i could keep him in my mind but
for to have an organization that
actually steps in and take care of these
kids it's just
it's just outstanding and it's an
outstanding organization
and i mean you know look at the impact
the the mentorship with an eighth grader
like everybody could use that but
especially someone that doesn't have
their parent
so just an awesome program i appreciate
what you're doing
and and what your whole team is doing um
i know that the
i know people are going to be interested
in you know in in trying to
find it so they can help out i know it's
a special ops.org
that's correct is is the website
instagram
is software fund fnd
uh twitter is software your fund fnd
so it's sof warrior fnd facebook is
at warrior foundation and you you also
actually have a youtube channel which is
a special
operations warrior foundation
i mean i think this is a good place to
wrap it up echo you got anything no sir
my pleasure no same here guys i really
appreciate the time and i i just got to
tell you didn't you know i didn't know
ahead of time you were going to tell
that story and read that letter
uh but that was really awesome man i
mean you know and to me it
you you get it you know what we're doing
and why we're doing it and
uh and i really appreciate you sharing
that yeah i was tempted to do it
in steve's steve's voice which would
have been like this man he had the most
epic voice i wish i could hear it one
more time man um
clay thanks for coming on thanks for
sharing your story with us
uh more important thanks for your
service
thanks for servicing the marine corps
oorah
in the army in special operations and
most important thanks for the service
that you continue to provide
for the entire special operations
community
thank you for taking care of our
brothers and sisters in arms
no worries it's my honor and a pleasure
and you know again i'm
i'm i'm a a small part of the team
but there's a whole group of committed
folks at the sowf who are very small but
100 committed to the success of these
families and being there for them you
know so it's a it's an honor
thanks for the support
and with that general clay
hot mocker has left the building
and once again echo charles seems like
we can do more
yes and at a minimum it seems like we
can do
better better yeah what can we do to do
better
well we can do a lot for sure uh
you know not all of us are going to be
flying through biblical dust storms
just save people and support people not
all of us
those those dust storms are crazy yes
sir
you don't want to be in one yeah flying
a helicopter
no see that i i imagine that that is
true
but in the event of us trying to support
others we need to be as capable as
possible
we'll just say that let's say you do for
whatever reason have to go through a
dust storm in any
situation scenario capacity how can we
be more ready for that
well let's start with physical physical
capability as much as you can
can't just start neglecting your
physical capabilities so we're working
out
we're doing jiu jitsu hopefully it's a
big deal
i feel like we've slacked on making it a
as it needs to be made it should be a it
is a big deal i think so too
so through our workouts exercising uh
we're reading hopefully some people suck
on that you gotta be honest
not this guy no i'm freaking reading so
much it's ridiculous
yeah but you know what right now i seem
to be i
you ever heard that thing when you're
mining you're mining
and you hit a vein of like gold where
you had a vein of silver
i'm like i like hit a vein with reading
i'm just starting to get these
books that are just stacking up and each
one i'm reading
i'll like open i wonder what this one's
about and i start going it's a vein
i just find a vein so that fear that i
want so it was a fear
when we started this podcast i was like
yeah i probably got 10
15 books to cover we'll be good
boy was i wrong boy was i wrong
yep so yes so we're reading so we're
reading working out physical
mental all that stuff moral too by the
way but that's a whole nother story
let's just start with physical mental
ideas
you're going to help us out with our
moral and spiritual
maybe health at this time okay maybe not
at this time okay
sticking with physical soul through
physical development we
we might need some supplementation it
helps don't worry jocko has
supplementation for us jackal fuel you
know i was about to commit a sin the
other day
what cracked open a discipline go i know
i stayed on the straight and narrow path
my spiritual health was strengthened but
that's
that's not a sin is it i said i was
about to commit a sin
oh and instead of committing the sin and
then i and then i cracked open
a disciplined go and i was able to get
back on yeah you were set free
on the righteous path right boom
spiritual health yeah i think we can you
know it's important
it's important 100 guaranteed yes so you
disappoint go you mentioned right can
you
can discipline be in a can can you just
have a
can of discipline oh actually factually
there you go i'm drinking it right now
okay so instead of
this okay this lingo in a can is for us
those of us who are kind of down for the
energy drink situation but we're not
down with the stigma or
what that energy drink situation might
entail
does entail from time from for the most
part not anymore though
no we're good yes clean energy healthy
after you drink it you're actually
better off you're actually trying to
pull you off topic and you're just
bringing it right back well for you
look these topics i'm not saying are
unimportant the ones that you're
bringing up or whatever and
they're just for another time yeah so
we're talking about discipline go right
now um also discipline go is
also in other formats powder
capsules capsules yeah so those are good
when you're when you're rolling into
something you gotta speak you got to
make something happen
you're going to be you're going to be
having to think on your feet
boom get it yeah so it's a it's a all
formats it's it's a mental
it's a mind boost insane so yeah boom
some people drink energy drinks out of
habits some people drink energy drinks
out of
or i just need a little bit of caffeine
or whatever all that's part of the game
too
but this one gives you an actual mental
cognitive
boost and physical boom so yeah get down
instead of your whack
and spiritual boost uh well you know you
know that's again that's what we're
talking about
uh also we got health supplementations
uh or supplementation for physical so
we've got
uh joint warfare for your joints keep
them in the game don't even have to
worry about them anymore also super
krill oil
there's a lot of studies i'm not going
to say the studies there's a lot of
studies that prove
the benefits of krill oil yeah you know
what's crazy is
the subscription rates on krill oil and
joint warfare
at jocko fuel
they're awesome yeah because people get
them and they're like oh yeah
subscribe yeah you will feel it yeah
it's just part of the routine now
because yeah we don't like worrying
about our joints
and here's the thing if you have to stay
if your bedroom is upstairs
and you wake up in the morning and you
got to walk downstairs you know when you
wake up that's when you're the most
stiff
arguably you're going to feel the
difference from day to day if you're on
the supercrew oil and joint warfare
that's the best combo my opinion
our opinion we'll just say general
consensus best combination
you're gonna feel the difference if
you're on it versus not on it when
you're walking down the stairs in the
morning that's the time you're gonna
really feel it not to mention when
you're lifting but you know that's
of course a whole another thing also for
your immunity
vitamin d3 and cold war two options for
immunity
boom also supplemental protein in the
form of a dessert
best tasting protein mix
on the market i kind of went i hadn't
had any mint chocolate for a while
probably like two weeks because i just
been just been
dialing in the peanut butter yeah which
is let's face it the peanut butter is
just
freaking delicious i am facing that
fully yeah but then last night
for my dessert after i had chicken
thighs
that my son cooked on the traeger they
might have been the best chicken i've
ever had think about that i believe i've
eaten a lot of chicken
yeah that might have been the best
chicken i and it was just
him and me and so we just were standing
there eating it
like plates whatever we're just standing
there he's got a
big big tray full of chicken
thighs and towards eating it and i eat
it
and i ate it was delicious i ate a bunch
but guess what i wanted when i was done
dessert i want a dessert bro i wanted
dessert
and i said peanut butter wait i could be
wrong peanut butter and chicken
is this this seems weird right it's kind
of weird
yeah anyways this the way this chicken
was cooked peanut butter wasn't going to
be
the thing i went back old school back to
my roots
and then chocolate chip that was good
perfect right so good so freaking good
so this is nobel prize belittle we be
little
who formulated these things you know
what put it together
i think i'm thinking nobel prize nobel
what priya what nobel e
nobel eat prize i don't know he's priced
straight up not peace
it brings peace let's face it i brought
peace to me last night
does your boy have a recipe for your uh
i will find out
i will find out and there could be luck
involved because let's face it you know
it was that good where you say man if
you could duplicate this tomorrow i'd be
impressed
one night i'm really impressed two
nights now you've got a situation you
need to open a restaurant
that's interesting i have a i have a
chicken thigh recipe too
chicken thighs are just good to go too
yes yeah
you do start ahead of the game with the
thighs in my opinion too
some people don't prefer that i do
obviously you do too but i got a recipe
too
that's why it interests me okay very
interested to see this go ahead ahead
let's have a little cook-off
and then you have the milk for the you
know you want any dessert with that yeah
i do
i want the milk right now yes sir uh so
yes
these uh items this supplementation
is available at jackalfuel.com but if
you want to go online you don't have to
shop online
let's go to wawa boom actually wall is
just for the energy just keep that in
mind
if you want the rest of the stuff you
can get a vitamin shop
and if you want to get this stuff
delivered to your house for free
well how is it going to get there for
free we're going to have to pay some no
for free go to jackofield.com
subscribe subscribe to that whatever it
is you want
it'll come whenever you want it it'll
come there for free boom
how freaking little [ __ ] is that yeah
yeah that's so we can do competition
with the
the elephant in the room right
the elephant in the room got some weight
behind it yeah
but we're over here scrapping right
we're over here scrapping oh you want to
throw down
some free shipping watch this
yes something very secure about a free
shipping scenario
it's like one of those things you just
don't have to worry about you know
it goes deep also origin maine.com
this is american-made stuff good durable
goods as it's called
i didn't quite know what that meant just
sounded durable which i like of course
but it's like jeans american-made denim
uh
we got some hoodies on there we got some
shirts on there we got some jujitsu
stuff
on there now when i say american-made
this is from the cotton that's grown in
south carolina
where is it north carolina the carolinas
it's in america i'll tell you that the
actual got the seeds
it's actually different it's actually
multiple locations where the cotton is
grown
multiple locations in america yes sir
boom
all the way up and at the end of the
chain you got a jiu jitsu
you got some denim jeans made hundred
percent uh
grown and sewn in america same thing
with the boots
by the way rift gee yes sir the rift key
it is another format of clothing
i don't know what else to make with that
thing but that material that the rift
key is
if you put it on if you wear a rift key
you will not you look you may wear
another key at some point
because you have to but you won't be
happy about it no that riff gee
is freaking legit i don't know what else
to make what else can we make with that
well we could go deep make some shorts
with that make up make a casual jacket
of some sort
i was thinking like uh you know when you
go to you go to mexico
and you get one of the you know like the
little baja jacket thing
you know what i'm talking about oh yeah
it's like a polo
maybe one of those maybe yeah it's
possible
yeah that'd be dope i think there's a
lot of options given the
yeah the fabric and the whole thing
here's the thing is it a catch-22
and i oftentimes think about this not
under
important circumstances just wondering
is it a catch-22 to have
a like comfort like that for you
it's not quite austere is it that's a
good point
but we are highly focused on capability
right
oh that's true yeah yeah so not only
does it comfortable
it's also highly capable because you go
to wash a regular ghee
and then you dry it out takes nine days
in the dryer to dry it out a regular
ghee
this thing's dizzing dry in 14 minutes
yeah
it's functionality bro is that about
comfort
back off functionality and
sustainability in the field
bro what if the what if you got a
regular key on
and then you're rolling it's hard you're
rolling with somebody
i don't know harder than you they go
harder than you they're better than
whatever they have more skills
and that gear is rubbing against your
neck not even in the submission
just rubbing against your neck versus
the rifgi
not rubbing against now or it could be
rubbing against your neck you don't feel
that concern it doesn't feel bad you're
too focused on your defense
right you see i'm saying so i get it
you're right okay so you're wearing
it yes uh info assimilated yes
boots t-shirts go to origin usa.com
that's what we're saying yes sir and get
cool stuff grab something speaking of
cool stuff
jaco has a store called jocko store cool
name
cool stuff this one equals freedom
shirts hats
hoodies some soap on there warrior kid
soap jocko soap trooper soap
killer soap the black charcoal
activated antibacterial soap have you
ever seen those videos
like on uh social media or whatever and
they're just
under the broad topic of satisfying
yes you've ever seen these things
because i don't watch those videos but i
my
category daughters will watch quote
satisfying videos right it's like a
piece of jell-o getting sliced it's real
weird stuff right
i don't get it but the closest thing i
have is when you take a
black soap which is killer soap
you wouldn't think that you could clean
yourself with black soap
yeah but it works it's so
satisfying i do understand and
yeah every once in a while you'll come
across something you're like yeah that
is i guess
given what you're saying as far as
satisfying goes yeah it's true
and yes the killer soap uh experience
we'll say
does fall under that category it kind of
has a uh what do you call it's not
abrasive
what's the lassiver what do you call it
exfoliation or
i don't know it's something in there
that provides a little scrub there you
go look at this guy with the exfoliation
on that one
nonetheless that's on jackal store as
well um
these are those these are american-made
soaps too straight up yeah
no chemicals in this kind of stuff by a
kid by the way that build building a
business
a warrior kid aiden the man providing
also
uh we have a subscription situation as
well
on joco store it's called the shirt
locker so these designs
are a little bit more i don't know how
to explain them i'm going to try they're
a little bit more maybe creative
maybe fun maybe they might jump out at
you a little bit more
a lot of people have been contacting me
saying that they want the shirt from
like two months ago
i have bad news and i have potential
good news bad news is you can't get it
it's because it's it was for that month
you see i'm saying if you're a
subscriber you'll get it and it's hard
to communicate like
oh these are going to be cool designs
because what does that even mean you
know
no one trusts you it's it's hard it's
hard to trust me
i'm not saying you but the proverbial
you the word trusts you
you say something's going to be cool
that's such a big opinion thing yeah
it's like you know how like
unquantifiable right so dean lister
mm-hmm
our friend oh dean list dean yeah he's
like hey i have this funny video
i'm gonna show you and he's like it's
real funny trust me
bro i'm looking at him bro i don't trust
you i trust you on a lot of stuff
not this you know you're about to waste
one minute and 38 seconds of your life
watching the dean list video of whatever
yeah whatever some abstract odd thing in
russia or whatever and
the video was like four and a half
minutes long i'm like so
right now i either suck it up and and
then waste four and a half minutes
or kind of offend dean lister which you
know depending on his mood
that might be a mistake in and of itself
nonetheless you see what i'm saying yeah
like just because dean says this video
is gonna be fun doesn't mean it's gonna
be funny so it's hard
so it's hard to trust opinions yes but
when it goes down and you already missed
it it's like man you kind of should have
trusted me a little bit
you seem saying that's kind of how it's
working sounds like a used car salesman
trust me
you know how about this do your best to
trust me okay that they're good and
there is gonna be [ __ ] be glad you
subscribe for this thing
we could say that the evidence of past
performance
of what'd you say cool t-shirts cool fun
desirable
evidence of that is strong very strong
and predicts possibly
high levels of coolness in the future
there is a significant amount of
regularity
in the satisfaction of the current and
past designs
yes check here's the good news maybe i
might bring one or two back
later i don't know when i don't know
which ones i don't know if it's even
gonna happen but i might
i don't know so anyway i think that's
illegal uh it it's possible but i'm
gonna sidestep some of the
red tape that i made by the way but i'm
gonna sidestep some of it and all so
this is what i'll do so
we have an email list on the store
shopstore.com
at the bottom if you sign up for that
email list if we do bring back
back past designs i'll email you
boom sign up for that check um speaking
of subscriptions you can subscribe to
this podcast
wherever you subscribe to podcast we got
some other podcasts we got jocko
unraveling with daryl cooper
we're going deep we're going dark too
it's get it's been getting real ugly
sorry that's the way the world is
you have to learn about history so that
you don't repeat it
we have the grounded podcast dean list
has been around
we need to get that one rolling warrior
kid podcast as well
you can also join us in the underground
we have jocko underground.com where
look we we are doing a podcast once a
week
we are doing this so that we have a
contingency plan we just did a podcast
that when we posted on youtube we got
i won't say we would again we got the
warning right
controversial whatever fact checking
it was about the armenian genocide and
and
look it's just an indication it's an
indication that we're not in control
so if that was to get really bad
we want to have a contingency plan
ready to execute so jocko
underground.com
if you want to help us be ready for that
happening we hope it doesn't happen but
if we have to you can help
us out that way we don't have to have
sponsors you only have to listen to echo
talk for
98 minutes at the end of a podcast but
you know you
first of all you're probably not even
listening right now second of all
first off it's very valuable information
that's first stuff
uh eight dollars and eighteen cents a
month if you can't afford it we don't
want you to not
be a part of the underground if you
can't afford it no problem
email assistance at
jockowunderground.com and we'll take
care of it we just want to
have a place to go should things
get crazy it's
true also youtube channel we have a
youtube channel for the video version of
this podcast
you know you want to see what our guests
look like or you just prefer the video
version which is a thing
said this for a while you play it on the
tv in the gym in the house
wherever you play it on a screen boom we
do have an
official youtube channel also there's
excerpts on there so you don't listen to
the whole podcast necessarily like
20 minutes before work or whatever or a
meeting or
some time constrained event you have
just listen to some of the excerpts get
the value what do you know about work
and meetings
and time constraints this is like i'm
learning i'm learning fast talk about
that we're good
we're good psychological warfare got an
album with tracks if you need a little
help overcoming some
momentary weakness i'll be there for you
press play
psychological warfare we've got flip
side canvas which is dakota myers
company where he's putting stuff for you
to hang on your wall
things that say dislike with freedom go
to flipsidecampus.com if you want to get
some of that got a bunch of books
i just posted a little post from final
spin what'd you think i liked it
yeah would you thanks it's funny because
i've kind of i've grown to know
you're kind of i don't want to say
signature but some things that are
pretty unique to you
when it comes to writing like the how
you'll start the margins like later and
later for a certain like
psychological psychological effect i
noticed some of that
but what was it wasn't necessarily
surprising as it was like oh i see what
you're doing there is
that you'll talk and it'll talk like
that and then it'll start to kind of
rhyme
in a way you'll be like oh okay all
right it's going to be very interesting
yeah the the reactions to that look i
posted one bits 200 pages i posted it
one page
and people were like what i was gonna
just my
my original caption was meet jessica
right that was i was gonna leave it at
that which i really wanted to but but
then i was like okay that's
let's face it we can be too vague in
life right that was a little that was a
little too vague
but yeah got a a
story novel poem
um transcript that's the new thing i
added to it
transcript because the dialogue in it
is just like a transcript this is what
someone said
there's no freaking you know
playing around with it this is a
transcript of what's been said
transcript poem book novel
yeah it's gonna it's gonna be
interesting yeah
it's interesting how you physically
write it adds to like what he call like
the experience you know
where you know a normal book cool love
it of course you know boom but it's
pretty
comparatively basic it's strange because
everybody that reads it gets that
it's like oh i know exactly what this
does
yeah it reads the same in your head
you're like boom boom boom eights
yeah there's a new new form of
literature boom choco my man yeah
that's gonna be good it's gonna be fun
for sure so check that out final spin if
you want that first edition
you know the deal leadership strategy
and tactics field manual the code the
evaluation of protocols dislikes freedom
field manual
brand new version weigh the warrior kid
four field manual and then you've got
one two and three as well
mikey and the dragons hackworth's about
face
and the og's extreme ownership and
dichotomy leadership
echelon front have a leadership
consultancy if you
need help in your organization
that help will come in the form of
leadership
go to ashlandfront.com if you want help
with the leadership inside your
organization we also do online training
efonline.com if you have a question for
me go to efonline.com
and i will be there monday wednesday
friday
i'll be there one two or three of those
days most of the time it's three of
those days
answering questions talking about
leadership the rest of the
echelon front team there as well we have
the muster which is a leadership event
live we didn't do any in 2020
because miss rona but miss rona has been
kind of handled at this point
people are vaccinated and whatnot so
luckily we made the decision to execute
orlando may 25th and 26th
there's still some seats left so if you
want to come to the muster go to
extremeownership.com
get there quick we don't have that many
seats left but we do have some seats so
if you want to come
that's may 25th and 26th after that's
gonna be
phoenix august 17th and 18th las vegas
october 28th 29th
get registered extreme ownership.com ef
battlefield
pay atten if you if you're interested in
doing that
we'll keep you posted it's an awesome
event
but we don't have another one on the
books right now as soon as we figured
out when we're going to do it
we'll i'll let you know and also if you
want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families check out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization and if you want to donate
or you want to get involved
well go to americasmightywarriors.org
and of course on top of that we also
have and you heard me talk about it
today
the special operations warrior
foundation you can go to special ops.org
you can go to instagram or twitter at
softwarefnd
and on facebook at warrior foundation
you can check that out
it's just you heard me it's a freaking
awesome organization
and if you want more of my where are
some witter
or you need more of echo's incongruous
interpretations you can find us on the
interwebs twitter instagram
otherwise known as the gram and facebook
echo is adequate charles
and i am at jocko willink and thanks
once again
to general clay hutmacher
for joining us and
for his incredible service and sacrifice
to this great nation and thanks to
everyone
at the special operations warrior
foundation for looking after our most
precious legacy the children of our
fallen heroes and thanks to all the
warriors in the military that are out
there right now standing watch
and keeping us safe from tyranny and
from evil and the same goes to those in
uniform here on the home front
our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service
and all other first responders thank you
for standing watch
here at home
and everyone else out there
remember what my friend and my brother
steve voigt
said before his last training mission
quote there is nothing that any person
cannot achieve if he or she has
the heart end quote
so you can do it
but do you have the heart and if you do
well then don't let the opportunities of
this life
go to waste instead go out there
and get after it and until next time
this is echo and jocko out